e
e e
it being 10:00 we will call the
committee finance committee meeting to
order on the 17th of April and the first
bill before us is Senate Bill 311 and I
want to recognize the sponsor Senator
Regina birdell good morning
Senator good morning Mr chair good
morning committee
thank for the record my name is Regina
berzel state senator for district 19
which encompasses the towns of Derry
Hamstead in
Windham and uh thank you for hearing
Senate Bill 311 um this is um this bill
makes an appropriation to the Department
of Health and Human Services and the
town of Hamstead to offset the reduction
in taxes uh from the state's acquisition
of Hamstead hospital um it appropriates
154,000 in fiscal year 2025 for the
purpose of Distributing funds to the
town of Hamstead to offset the impacts
on that Town's tax base from the state's
purchase of Hamstead
hospital um the bill requires uh DHHS uh
to make a total payment to hset of
191,0 in fiscal year
2025 and the remaining
37166 would need to be allocated from
the Department's existing Appropriations
I would say we
um uh it was supposed to be in the
budget otherwise I wouldn't have to be
here but it got missed out of the budget
so um I I'm here uh submitting Senate
Bill 311 so if you have any questions I
know Nathan is back here from DHHS he
can kind of go into a little bit more of
detail and he will come and testify to
us any questions for Senator
birdell representative papovich Muer
thank you Mr chairman thank you senator
for taking questions um obviously the
bill only allocates the funds for the uh
current budget uh year is is it the
intent to have this as a one-time
appropriation to ease the
unexpected transition of the state to
state property or is there a thought
that this should be a more long-term
appropriation I think every year it has
to like I said it was supposed to go
into the budget um for a two-year period
so for the next um this year and I
believe next year I will be submitting
submitting it and then next year it'll
go into the budget for um but we have to
recertify it I believe every two years
thank you further questions from
committee seeing none repres
representative Maguire thank you Mr
chairman thank you senator for
coming does the state in the budget do
similar things for other properties the
state has purchased they do thank
you further questions from committee
members seeing none thank you senator
thank you we'll next call on Nathan
white Chief Financial Officer for the
Health Department of Health and Human
Services good morning members of the
committee Nathan white CFO with the
Department of Health and Human Services
um I'm going to provide a little bit of
context and background just for the
members uh on June 8th uh
202022 the department acquired Hamstead
hospital um um in state fiscal year 2022
the department with Governor executive
Council approval previously made
approximately
$176,000 payment to the town of Hamstead
um to address the increased costs and
also the loss of property tax revenue um
I think it's important to understand
that a town um cannot tax the state um
we the state is exempt from that in
state fiscal year 23 we also made
another
$178,000 payment to the town of Hamstead
with executive Council approval and um
the amount that you see here within the
bill on line four the 191,192
budget for Hamstead General funds um and
that's the difference between the
$154,000 that's being appropriated here
versus the total amount that the
department will pay which is the
$191,000 to the town of Hamstead through
an unencumbered payment
request thank you for that explanation
representative tki for a question thank
you Mr chairman thank you Mr White we
just heard that the state does this for
other um buildings or pieces of land
they own um two-part question can you
give us an example of one of those and
number two um is that just an ongoing um
payment that goes into the budget and
maybe it's sort of not that it's buried
but we just don't see it as a normal um
budgeting cycle sure so to answer your
first question um I I would probably
defer to the Department of
administrative services on other
agencies that make these type of
payments um this is the only type of
payment Within the Department of Health
and Human Services budget um but but
ultimately I would defer to the
Department administrative Services they
have much better awareness what other
agencies are paying
for um when it comes to the budget uh we
did at during the Senate phase um the
the the Senate finance committee had
approved an appropriation um that would
have shown up in the current operating
budget um that is not in the operating
budget when we submit this when we
submit the state agency budget for State
fiscal years 26 and 27 that will not
necessarily be part of the efficiency
expenditure budget or the base budget um
that if if that was included that would
be a prioritized need um but ultimately
that is a a policy decision that I will
defer to all of the members of Finance
on representative Heath for a question
thank you Mr Cher and thank you for
taking my question
um I find it somewhat precedent setting
um I would ask does the city of
Manchester get re reimbursed for YDC
being in the city of
Manchester do you know no
um the city of Berlin they have a state
prison do they get reimbursed no thank
you very
much F questions from committee members
represent Petri and then represent
Stringham thank you Mr
yeah thank you Mr chairman and why not
why why do you know that would be the
next question why why doesn't those
cities get well I I I think you have to
look at the history uh associated with
this so um the Department of Health and
Human Services and the state acquired
the organization the Hamet Hospital uh
in
um at that point in time there were
discussions with the town during the
acquisition process relative to the
impacts because ultimately you know this
is going to have some impact on the on
the local Town finances um and there
were discussions at that point in time
um to address that through uh these
payments um and as Senator burel
indicated before um this payment would
be for uh State fiscal year 25 uh for
the remainder of this Bia um after that
point in time I think it would
ultimately be a policy decision that the
legislature would need to decide on
thank representative stringam for would
it be fair to call this somewhat
analogous to a payment in Le of taxes a
pilot payment yes some people have
referred to it as the pilot um for the
acronym relative to that yes okay and
and um You referred to some things
outside of Health and Human Services uh
since some of us just went to Glen Cliff
to the town of Warren or Benson get any
pilot uh type payments uh for the Glen
Cliff facility and anything for New
Hampshire hospital for where that is uh
no not for glencliffe there's obviously
a very long history there um dating back
many decades um so I don't know what
discussions occurred at that point in
time okay and New Hampshire hospital is
and I don't know if that would be
analogous or
not uh no New Hampshire hospital is a
little unique in the sense that our
first responder Services we have State
uh police um through the department of
safety through anou with the Department
of safy
uh through which we compensate State
Police for providing those services on
campus okay um followup followup do you
have any um uh comments on why it's in
the overall State interest to uh to make
these pilot payments um uh to
Hamstead you I think that question is
starting to delve into policy and um
again I would kind of look at the
history here where the state acquired a
hospital um with uh not a sign acquired
a hospital midyear that has a
significant impact on the on the local
Town's finances um and ultimately what
what had been decided and through
negotiations at that point in time was
we would be we would make those payments
which we have done for the past two
years and as Senator burel had indicated
Senate Finance had voted to approve this
um into the budget obviously there's no
committee at conference this past year
um so there was no discussion between
the house and the Senate on that topic
uh but again this would this would be a
decision for for the members thank
you further questions for this witness
from committee
members represent Maguire thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question what was the condition of the
hospital when the state acquired it was
it was it an ongoing business was it
empty was it something sure it was owned
and operated by a private organization
from which we acquired
it followup so it it was full of
patience and so on so now the the
residents of Hampton have to go even
further when they want to need a
hospital is that it was a children's
psychiatric hospital so so the the the
major difference which I believe um the
commissioner and our Deputy Commissioner
have uh discussed with a number of
members of various committees has been
we we've seen a change in uh the the
census relative to Acuity uh we are
rather than um some of the children that
are there now rather than being sent out
of state um they're now being treated at
Hamstead Hospital rather than being
moved
elsewhere thank
you further for this witness then the
next witness will probably Enlighten us
a little more because representative
Guthrie is also a selectman might have
been in on some of this negotiation so
there's no further questions for Mr
White I'll call on representative
selectman Joe
Guthrie probably should have taken you
in different
order
morning get your red light on there you
go thank you uh just for the record I'm
Joe Guri uh uh representative uh from
Hamstead and I'm here really with the
other hat which is that I'm a selectman
in Hamstead have been for a long time
and I'm also a member of the planning
board so our understanding is this is
the only uh uh way that we can get any
money in lure of taxes and when we
started out that's the way we were
were're trying to present them to the uh
executive committee and when at the
first time we had a payment which thank
you very much by the way uh and this is
a facility coming into our community uh
in that they although they purchased the
Hamstead Hospital in the in the very
near future they're going to expand that
so we see a real impact on our uh town
and as I say this the only vehicle we
have to uh get uh uh the the funds as a
a tax offset if you will so uh we
appreciate very much that you're taking
this under consideration it came through
the process with unanimous support uh we
think that uh it's fair that this
facility coming into our community uh
should participate in uh assisting the
town in the cost of uh services that we
will provide for them having represented
uh Hamstead at the time I believe there
was
negotiations with the town by the the
HHS to see see if it would be supported
by the town because that's correct if it
had not been supported by the town they
may have gone elsewhere but one of the
reasons the town supported it was
because you've got a lot of acreage
there to to do fire protection on and
and police yes it's an it's an ideal
place for the hospital I personally
think the selection was good uh the only
concern we had was the impact it was
going to have on our community
right so I'm glad you're here with the
experience of that negotiation any
questions representative papich M thank
you Mr chairman and thank you
representative gri for taking questions
same question that I had for uh Senator
berel is this meant to be a one-time
payment to ease into the transition or
do you see this as a permanent
replacement for the property taxes that
you you know would no longer be able to
charge well because of the process
pretty hard to forecast what's going to
happen but my understanding is this is
for uh a two year like a two for two
years and then we have to go through the
process again asking this is the only
vehicle we have for funds and the town
will be making that request to our
Senator at that time thank you so just
to confirm that I understand correctly
it is your intent to continue seeking
such uh Appropriations on a ongoing
basis we hope to make the request
thank you and hopefully it would be uh
be done if uh this goes forward thanks
representative Petry for a question
thank you Mr chairman uh do you think
that this is going to attract any other
ancillary businesses uh because of the
facility Well that's pretty hard
to uh to say I would say maybe it could
very well uh we have the uh we the where
the all to provide any Services uh
particularly Commercial Services that
the hospital might need but uh what will
happen in the future if this will I
don't see this impacting on uh any
commercial uh interest in the in the
town I do recall at one of the hearings
there was a a woman that was in a butter
that was also had the contract for
landscaping I don't know whether that
would continue or whether state would
have their own employees doing care
doing that so that that was one area
that she was fear fearful of losing that
contract and I guess she probably has
yeah well I I can understand that she
she is an a butter and uh you know it's
a she talking about a business concern
concern but she had a number of concerns
being in a butter and she had
a opportunity to voice those as we went
through the process
y I remember that representa hacken
Phillips thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question um I just want to clarify uh
one of your earlier statements about the
negotiation period leading up to the
acquisition by the state uh was it is it
am I correct in understanding that you
said the condition to
sell was um Reliant upon the state's
ongoing commitment to to make these
payments
I'm sorry I don't understand was it a
condition of the
sale that the town would be relying upon
the state's continued tax payments not
my understanding it was something we had
to negotiate we had to go through the
executive councel uh with the help of
the Health and Human Services
commissioner who at that time would uh
supported the request uh but uh that was
the only vehicle we had so just a quick
follow
um so then the town did not make the
decision to sell the location based on
the understanding they would be
reimbursed for these tax
payments uh no in fact you know it was
just pretty almost a taking and the town
was not involved except that we uh went
through the Health and Human Services as
as a as a negotiation uh after the fact
after it was purchased but there was
investigation as to the site and there
was a lot of discussion about that was
determine he hampson was the best
location but there was no
commitment uh in fact to tell you the
truth we were sort of mad as hell uh if
I could say as a town know here comes
something uh and uh we had no way of
reimbursing uh for we all of a sudden we
found out we couldn't tax
at the state so sure and just a quick
followup Mr chair um so it's fair to say
that the town was not a party to the
transaction so that this contemplated
future payment of tax reimbursement kind
of making the town hle was not within
the arms length negotiation of the
actual sale itself you not the sale so
thank
you representative tersi thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking my question can you speak briefly
as a member of the local board um about
the impact um of recent um necessary um
visits to the property um by emergency
response um and town response by police
or ambulance I I think I heard that um
the city has had to respond to a number
of incidents and I'm just curious if
there is a uh price tag you might have
for any of those
well there have been some incidents and
and you have to realize they just the
state has just purchased a hospital
that's a small part of what it's going
to be there's going to be another large
of uh facility there uh so it's going to
expand uh and uh the state uh my
understanding the state nearest State
Troopers uh uh station is in eeping
that's sometime
you know talking about maybe a 20 minute
uh
uh time frame to get to the hospital uh
so in all Essences uh our own fats and
and Fire have to have had to perform any
services so it's almost it's a local
facility being serviced by the local
police and fire and followup follow up
so just to Conn the dots though if
there's an incident at this property
local First Responders need to respond
for the safety of everybody and someone
has to pay for that I.E the town and um
this bill would help provide NE some
necessary funds that you know don't have
at this point in time well I don't as
far as I know on the time Town side
that's has yet to be a an evaluation of
what the impact is going to be but we
know we've already had to put additional
police on staff okay we've had a two
police officers which we probably would
not have Okay uh you know it's kind of a
back door thing you you do something you
say that's why you did it uh
but they are together that we did add at
least two police officers and we our
rambulance servic is going to be
stressed think the contract we have now
went up to something like 300,000
for ambulance service not just for for
hamon hospital but for the town thank
you all right thank you representa lean
for a
question thank you Mr chairman thanks
for taking my question so I had served
on a nonprofit board and we used to pay
the municipal share of the taxes to the
town it's like a good faith effort
because of the impact that this uh
organization I served on had on the town
you know if that
$150,000 is that the entire loss of
taxes or is it the municipal share or
both the school and Municipal assessment
of that property my understanding was a
calculation of the tax rate and the uh
uh what we were getting what what the
value of the property was was like a
back door thing and it was was an
estimate uh I I can't uh really thought
it was low I think it was when we
originally were looking at it was over
$200,000 but it was just a calculation
that was made based on our tax rate and
what the impact would have been if we
could tax it which we couldn't okay and
we have other like there's a
organization T NOA is in our town and
they pay us a in lure of taxes that we
could can do that with a uh that kind of
a concern with the state this is the
only vehicle we have okay thanks thanks
Mr chairman representative do you recall
it was uh Hamstead Hospital the largest
property
taxpayer
oh I know they're not they're not so but
I don't know what the rating is but they
would not the largest taxpayer in town
thank you further questions from
committee
members represent Heath thank you Mr
chair just a quick one um do you know if
um the New Hampshire State Police have
you set up an agreement with them to
help out in terms of the needs that um
occur at Hamstead because there have
been many it seems just watching the
television it seems like they're always
um your local police or the state police
are going is there an agreement with the
state police
to help out to mitigate your issues well
it's in their District so I it's their
responsibility but I there is if far
there's no no you do one thing we'll do
something else for you it's nothing not
like that it's their responsibility is
in their
District I think there's also the
likelihood the sheriff might be called
Sheriff's a little closer than the state
police but not
much but both of them are fairly distant
they're not in the same town three four
towns away so further questions from
committee thank you representative thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for giving
me the opportunity to come before you
and make this request appreciate your
expertise I'll B
Ham this is uh about 9,000 people in
Hamstead
so okay there's nothing further we got a
5 minute break until we uh get to Senate
Bill 3:47 scheduled at 10:30 and I'm
waiting for pink cards for the people
that wish to testify on that bill so
five minute break folks and then we'll
start again at 10:30 thank you
testified thank
you there was there was no opposition to
this bill at this point conquer wanted
it thank
you e
represent Lehman you you may want to
talk about U I'm going to meet at the
lunch break with the division
chairs I know that's what I want
division chairs to hear me that we'll
meet so if you want to schedule
something for next week we want to get
it in the calendar today by 1:00 so
we'll have a quick meet at by the
division chairs Vice chair at at around
noon or whenever we break to discuss if
you want to have meetings next week I
think most of these bills are going to
go division
one all
right
e
e e
the people that that are here to speak
on Senate Bill
347 um relative to infrastructure
Appropriations for reimbursement to the
city of lonia the sponsors our Prime is
Senator Lang then Senator gray Senator
Carson Senator inis representative
Moffett representative B
representative bogert representative St
Clair anybody seen any of those
folks all right then if uh I'll ask
representative Maguire to introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I'd like to introduce
Senate Bill 347 it appears I I have not
read it but it appears it allocates $3
million for this
banum um to the Department of
administrative services to pay to the
City of Laconia for expenses related to
public water sewer and road
infrastructure um on on the uh related
to the um former lonia State School
campus property so um I will not answer
questions thank you very good
all
right you have
am I can't make a comment on all
right representative Earth thanks Mr
chair so I'll point out that the Senate
actually takes really good minutes of
their meetings and there is you can find
on their on our G uh Court website all
right if everyone will listen up then
representative Earth's going to give you
a brief of what happened in the no I'm
not I'm not going to read it to you I'm
just going to tell you that you can go
find the Senate minutes for this bill on
the website if you're interested in the
details of what's behind it in terms of
who said what about it during their uh
public hear anything
significant oh you want me to read it
we've got time all right so this is
Senator Lang's
testimony this bill would use $3 million
from the sale price of the lonia state
school project to offset infrastructure
costs for the City of Laconia as needed
to develop the project the project is
slated for 1,000 homes 400 of which will
be affordable housing the goal is to
reduce potential impact fees normally
the city would charge the infrastructure
costs as impact fees to the developer
that cost in turn would be added to the
price of the new homes the anticipated
infrastructure cost will be both Water
and
Sewer this is a step we can take as new
money coming to the state currently not
earmarked for anything in particular
love that
one SB 347 FN does not write a check to
the city of lonia for $3 million instead
the Department of administrated Services
would hold the amount in escro the city
would then submit invoices to the
department up to the $3 million for
those infrastructure
costs that's from sen langing Andrew
Hosmer the I hope I have that pronounced
correctly is the mayor the city of lonia
and he testified in
favor this is a significant project the
parcel of land has been under State
control for over 100 Years hopefully the
sale will close within the next couple
of
months These funds will support over 400
units of affordable housing similar to a
TIF district and I don't know what that
is tax increment funding okay it will
only be funded once properties have been
built and you've been able to segregate
some funds I assume by UV he means State
been able to segregate some funds and
put it into the Tiff account this bill
allows the city to do so they will
partner with the developer and upon the
sale the proceeds would go to the
state probably we need him here to
really explain this this will enable the
start of some of that infrastructure
work that needs to be done to be done
early the city council lonia city
council submitted written testimony to
members of the Comm committee I don't
have that Senator gray inquired as of
the state's asking price Mr Homer
indicated it was an open bid the winning
bid was 21.5 million state will receive
a net of 20 million 16 million was
allocated for another project last year
in the budget maybe that's where Senator
Lang is talking about the $2 million
that they haven't figured out how to
spend yet comes from uh Senator delandro
stressed his concern for this project
the closing date on the sale has been
pushed off numerous times as we all know
I think the bidder needs to deliver on
what it bid it is a very valuable piece
of property and Senator Lang again
stated the governor and executive
Council expect the sale to close by the
end of January well they obviously miss
that um and they're still working on it
in case you're not aware of this mayor
Hosmer offered the closing was postponed
to January 15th it's been postponed I
think two or three times since which was
sort of a drop dead date where they kept
it alive from the governor executive
councel he understands the state is not
completed some of their obligations
regarding due diligence the closing may
very well get pushed into February and
now we're here we are in April so that
was it for the testimony there was no
testimony opposed or or neutral thank
you very much we now know a lot more
than we did when we first introduce the
Bill thank you um what I'll do is uh
we'll go into recess on this bill and if
anybody shows up that says oh oh I'm
here for 347 we'll open that bill again
if there's
this time what's
that
yes thank you Mr chairman so um I just
wanted to briefly uh talk to the
committee um I I handed out
uh this piece of paper um house bills
with significant General and education
fund costs this is um just a subset of
of what uh Mike Kane sent you uh he had
a more detailed spreadsheet but this
this is sort of the big ticket items I
believe there is one big ticket Senate
bill yet to come which with like a $60
million allocation for
YDC uh for the lawsuit ass thing so um
but the main thing I wanted to talk
about
is how should we proceed from now
forward because if we just sort of pass
bills willy-nilly and not uh um and not
have some kind of grand total I mean the
the reason the budget
Works to the extent it does is is we
both pass it but then we get together
normally and and work out the
differences so that so that the amount
we have meets the amount we spend but
these are all individual bills and so we
don't really have a mechanism for saying
okay our you know the grand total we
have to spend is X and and the amount of
these bills has to be X or something
less than x right so so my suggestion to
the Senate and I'm not sure they've
taken me up on it yet but is that for
any Senate Bill we pass or any house
bill they pass we should never pass it
OTP we should always pass it
otpa with some kind of an amendment and
then um the other body should say okay
we want a committee of conference on
this and then in it we could have a kind
of joint committee of conference for put
together all the bills and talk about
them as a group if you see what I mean
so that that's my suggestion is if it's
a really trivial bill right I mean if
it's $100,000 or something that's fine
to OTP but if it's one of these or or
something big like that Millions then I
think we should always OTP a you know
obviously if we want itl that's no big
deal right but but if we want
OTP my suggestion is find some kind of
an amendment and that way it it allows
the process to continue and it allows us
to get together with the Senate um and
and look at the Grand totals thank you
good good suggestion when we uh got
finished with all the bills last
Thursday um and that's why I was trying
to get the uh
the 1560 off the table so we could fund
the ones that needed general fund which
most of those were 25 to Zer that we
passed out of the
house there was 70 million that were
only could be funded with general fund
79 million that could be funded with
education trust fund or general funds so
there's 149 million there in those 40
bills now we're looking at 22 bills of
the 100 so I think we sent 300 107 to
the Senate and do you remember the
number coming back over 10
something7 was it that high the number
of Senate bills now in the house
committees is 177 177 so they're you
know somewhere around
half so obviously if we add up all these
bills when we get done and see what the
uh what the totals come to and take
another look at what is actually in in
the Surplus and the surus us may be more
or less than what we what we heard of a
couple of months
ago so we should not spend more than
what what is there and then I suppose
we're going to hear in fiscal on
Friday that the spend thrifts in the
sonunu um suit want another 60 or 70
million
which unless it's coming in other fiscal
years I don't think we can give them
um so we got one 347 yet oh we do okay
good that was
you thank you for filling that out so
anyway those are the issues as I see if
any anybody else sees any other issues I
appreciate you bringing all that up
these are the things we're going to have
to keep in mind as we look at these
various bills and think of ways they
could be reduced or could be put off
until the next budget those are things
we'll have to keep in mind as we go
through all these demands for money Mr
chairman we've already passed several
representative member yes uh uh
1583 and 1656 would be coming out of the
educational trust fund so there there
there are funds available for those
three out outside of General funds the
money will be coming in from them yes
where's it coming from it's just trust
fund uh the trust fund oh oh well the
education trust fund yeah that's all the
money is that's what I say 79
million was from education trust fund of
the bills we passed Thursday but 70
million was from the general fund right
I when when we began all that
anticipation we were going as high as
200 million because we believed that was
the Surplus and so we were kind of
massaging all those bills to get it
under that 200 million and uh we were
successful but now we've got to be faced
with what's coming up next and as
representative McGuire points out these
are all going to be negotiated things
and uh we're going to go over to the
senate make sure that they don't just
because I had a brief conversation with
with the chairman of the Senate Finance
which was unsatisfactory I don't know if
he serious I said we're sending you a
bunch of bills you want to discuss them
we'll just kill them
all that's the kind of reaction we have
then we can do the same over here we
could do the
same but
all right if there's nothing further on
347 or on the process going forward
we'll take a break until 11:00 when
we'll be looking for Senate's Bill
393 again I I'll put out one call for
Senate Bill 347 anybody wishes to
testify on that otherwise we'll recess
it until sometime later today and if
somebody shows up we're in recess thank
you
e
e e
there is is okay
we
any yeah yeah but who
else thank
you it being 11 o'clock we'll call it
house committee on finance to order and
we'll be hearing now Senate Bill 3 93
and we'll call on the prime sponsor
Senator
abis welcome to house
finance good morning good morning I'm
Senator Daryl abbis I represent District
22 serving the communities of pelum
Salem ACC and plastow I'm I'm here as
the prime sponsor to introduce Senate
Bill
393 many of you may be familiar with the
water
you know infrastructure projects that
been done in Southern New Hampshire over
the last few years uh as written it's
really this is for phase two of that
project uh phase one and to the credit
of when phase one was done a lot of the
uh piping that was laid was done in
anticipation of phase two you really
wouldn't have had a phase one without a
two so a we did there was a lot of cost
savings there but right now what uh I
know for at least Salem the water rights
have already been purchased uh it's
really just completing the
infrastructure uh that would deliver to
that Community 1.2 million gallons of
water per day uh this could also service
Hamstead ainson plasta would benefit
obviously Dairy would have benefits as
well and there's a lot wind HX would uh
could potentially receive benefits too I
know they weren't as receptive of the
potential of water in initially but I
hear they're warming up to it but when
it comes to water supply you know you
hear a lot about housing and you hear a
lot about ways we can improve our
infrastructure you can't do that without
utilities you can't do without energy
you can't do without water you it it's a
necessary uh part of the the future so
in Salem I you we take a lot of pride in
saying this we led the way in Housing
Development throughout the state but
part of it is is to continue those
efforts you do need utilities uh right
now uh our two main water sour forces
are cany Lake and Arlington Pond you
know in the summertime is when Cy lake
is drawn from that's a that's a natural
spring Fred Lake and then Arlington pond
it's a man-made lake normally in the
winter time switch over uh there's been
some contamination issues with um
Arlington Pond the new guidelines from
the federal government with with pasas
aside which my understanding is the
levels are around six to eight parts per
trillion they just came out with a um
saying otherwi that four parts per
trillions is a problem but that issue
aside you had a cal bacteria problem as
well uh residents could not swim in that
Lake for most of the summer and I
believe they were delayed when we
switched over to that water supply and
we normally would do that around mid
October we actually delayed it and the
reason for that we were able to delay
the switching over because of the Heavy
Rain Cy Blake's levels were at a
sufficient level um however one of the
concerns was is whether there was even
an ability to filter something that
water now the cause of the sin bacteria
problem there's a several factors that
contribute to that one of them uh I
understand there's no uh Municipal uh
services in respect to water or sore up
in that part of town we call that North
Salem where I live and I'm not saying
that there an appetite to you know put
those Services there however we don't
have a sufficient Supply to even do that
if we wanted to it's not even a
conversation to have you can't do it um
I know with some of the development
we've done we been very fortunate but to
continue and finish off a lot of this
having a sufficient water supply is
necessary um if anything ever happened
with cany Lake which my understanding is
the uh pest levels in there again when
they're not alarmingly high but they're
over that four part per trillion and
that's the main main water supply uh for
the summer months but again you know
living I live on that body of water I
see how low it can get drawn down if you
have a drought season so there
are as there water short shortage I
would say no but it wouldn't take much
for for that to really come to a
realization but I think when it comes to
Future developments really in Southern
New Hampshire you can't we cannot
continue to do it without the water now
there is a uh I did email the committee
last night of a suggested Amendment uh
so phase two there's a lot of in some
brighter Minds we'll talk about the
price tags of how that phase could be
done there was some thought of perhaps
breaking phase two into you know 2 a 2 B
and 2C to break it up over time this
project is going to take several years
so perhaps we what we don't want to have
it happen is we sit here in kind of as
stalemate waiting around and not doing
anything while meanwhile when you have a
problem you can't say we didn't know
about it so we have an opportunity now
to get ahead of things and make sure
that there's a sufficient water for
everyone uh there's some talks about
some raising the lake level in
Manchester I know there's a lot of lot
of moving Parts here and there's some
better Minds that can speak on this than
myself
but I will say that uh when it comes to
Future developments at least in Southern
New Hampshire I think investing in
infrastructure that includes clean
drinking water is a necessity so and
I'll take any
questions thank you Senator questions
from committee members for Senator
abbis Senator Petri then representative
Petri then representative Emer you
go good morning thank you Mr chairman uh
good morning Senator nais my old
seatmate
and uh is there already a program to
help uh municipalities to uh take care
of the water
situations so there's some when it comes
to now just to clarify you talk about
cleaning contaminated water or no this
is this is Municipal Water new new
sources when when
it well goes dry they you know they uh
have to find a new well and the whole I
our our town is going through the same
thing right now and we I don't think we
got $25 million from the state to help
us out
so the issues is is when this project
was done in the first place uh you had
several you two phases to it the first
phase was already done and the water
rights were purchased by each community
that choose that was part of the project
so that was paid for at the local level
and then a lot of the money that went
into this it was was Federal funding and
the suggested Amendment does divide it
up between the general fund and some
Chan uh some opportunities for federal
money as well that we're trying to work
out here but this is a when I said
there's an opportunity not because
you're well went dry that we're not
talking about one or two properties here
we're talking about an entire region the
water supply and not just the wells
going dry it's we're talking about
future developments future housing to
really get into that and to really make
a commitment to that it's really hard to
to have that conversation without a
guarantee that those resources will be
available I understand not every
Community has an appetite for housing
developments and all that Southern New
Hampshire Salem where I live has shown
that appetite but to continue that
progress forward without uh Assurance of
having the resources available would be
irresponsible there would be some you
would eventually hit a wall there so
there's also you know contamination
issues there's there's funds right now
set up um at the state level where you
can get some money through some
contamination issues but the total Phase
2 project we're talking can be around 30
to $40 million uh that's why breaking up
over several um several installment uh
making phase two basically three parts
might be the best way to go followup
follow up all right um yeah now I lost
my train of thought boy that's that's
bad that was my
goal keep talking to you
forget that that was a goal
okay uh okay I'll pass representative
Emer for a question yes uh Mike my
community is serviced by a private water
provider are these grants Andor loans
available to private water
suppliers I'm not sure to the answer
answer to that but I can I can look in
and try to get a I I think what what it
the overall is really for the it's the
infrastructure as a whole I don't I
don't know
if the private developer can apply for
that that's that I can't
answer thank you do you remember I
remember Mr chairman uh where's this
money coming from so the suggested
Amendment does leave some money uh it's
for some federal funding It's a
combination of that and then you have
the uh trust fund already that's set up
with some of the M relating to Pas
contamination which I will say just
recently the guidelines that came out by
the feds would put both of Salem's Water
Supplies over that four parts per
trillion uh we are asking for some some
money from the general fund as
well representative Abel yes thank you
thank you very much Senator I could you
clarify how phase one was
funded of the project I think I think
most of that came from the the trust
fund in the first place I'm not 100% on
where it all came from um this was
something that uh Senator Morris really
championed as when he was in the Senate
and got this going and now this is the
next phase so to me I think it's a an
obligation to carry that through but I
know when that trust fund that we have
now with a lot of the PS U money goes I
believe some of it came from there is
that it's the commission that uh
represented boy now is the uh chair
of Representative camell for question
thank you Mr chair thank you Senator
abis for taking the question um the
federal funds that you mentioned that
may be available are they tied to or
dependent upon us giving you money from
the state so thank you for the question
I think it's the other way around I
think we actually have to pass this
first they go to them and ask them for
money to set it aside on the condition
that we pass legislation that's not how
it would work I know there's been a lot
of effort on on from a lot of different
individuals contacting our federal
delegation to try to get some commitment
on what can be done because again we
hear about housing we keep hearing about
this and they keep talking about how
everyone wants to help and and I'm
telling you one way to to do that we
need to have the municipal Services the
communities that aren't interested in
putting these housing developments there
I mean that's that's a local control
issue that they make that choice but
when you have communities that are
buying into that and are actually
contributing towards making more housing
I mean Salem Alone um I can't give you
the exact amount but we you know they're
building 300 units right now they've
already built I would say close to a
thousand units on top of single family
homes you know they just approved the
planning board just approved another six
units to go across the street from the
Tuscan Village so we're doing our end in
that Community but at the same time I
think keeping those Municipal Services
is is needed and there's a lot of
benefit that the state as a whole gets
from that I mean the increased in
economic activity that leads to more
revenue from all whether it's rooms and
meals tax whether it's people coming
here for you know business profits tax
there's a lot that goes into that
obviously the property taxes both at the
state and federal uh state and local
level there's a lot of different
benefits the state has but to continue
to ask communities to do it without
without sufficient resources I I don't
know I don't see that going forward
anymore thank you representative papich
M thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for uh answering questions and
for
testifying um I'm trying to better
understand the equity right investments
in
infrastructure that are paid from State
money should try to you know benefit the
state overall and obviously building a
water pipeline is a you know Regional
project
right in terms of community support you
know being from wiam I haven't really
monitored this closely but yeah I would
probably bet that as the low standards
on pasas come lower and lower there will
be more of an appetite but I'm trying to
understand communities like that have
been hugely affected you know like in
the merac area do they have access to
the same resources you know what what
can we do for other parts of the state
so that everybody has you know similar
opportunities there is a way to argue
that you know higher density communities
need water first because they are more
likely to strain their local Water
Supplies but just what are your thoughts
on
this whole picture for the state so you
said it well when you said it's a
regional project meaning if you're
asking let's say you want Salem OR
Windham or one town to really pay into
it the problem is this pipeline it
coming out from Manchester it's going
all the way down comes through dairy uh
you need the communities to buy into it
which is one part of it so when it comes
to where that this should go I know
right now when it comes you know Hudson
London der also had some issues you know
there this project and I think some
other people that will testify after me
can talk really about the details of
this but there's not a single community
that doesn't have the opportunity to get
relief from the state in trying to deal
with their water supply issues but again
this takes a commitment from a lot of
different uh people and entities because
it you you need the water supply you
need the developers you need the
community appetite and then also people
want to know what the what's the water
going to be used for people aren't going
to just send a water supply without any
direction what's happening with that
water I mean so I think they're trying
to Target and balance that out uh Salem
we we have a population of over 30,000
people all right and we're we're still
growing I mean I said 300 units are
being uh they're building that as as we
speak now so again we're we're we're
growing as a town but I mean wind him's
grown a lot significantly um I know
Dairy is grown and not not quite the
same rate as Salem um now Hamet and
ainson in plasa they have some
contamination issues as well so again uh
it's really tough on for some parts some
places to improve or do any type of
development without having the resources
I know Windham they were not necessarily
supportive of the water there's no we're
not putting any strings to this that you
have to have lot size requirements or
you have to do this we're just saying
this is the water supply if we want to
trust the uh communities to use that
water uh in the right way and they're
GNA buy into it so that's that's how
that works thank you I just want to
point out that wiam did not approve the
warrants when they asked to actually
build a pipeline but we did uh pay for
water rights through the system I
remember personally dropping that check
off because it was too big to mail in my
personal opinion so uh that was a fun
card trip with you know few Millions
what's a few Millions between friends um
and I do appreciate the willingness of
Salem to build I know that a lot of the
times people U Want housing build just
not in their communities it's kind of
refreshing to see Salem build it in
their own town and maybe people won give
wind him such a hard time if you if
Salem had some water to build some more
housing committee members good luck
thank you we're halfway through our a
lot of time and we have three more
people to speak you may hear the answers
that you might have looked for if we can
just move on to the other the experts
are behind me that's right thank you
Senator next call on commissioner Robert
Scott from Department of Environmental
security thank you uh for the record my
name is Bob Scott again I'm commissioner
with the Department of rml Services I've
asked uh the engineer who's responsible
for
the dees engineer who's responsible for
the phase one as uh project as we were
discussing uh to sit up with me he's
passing out our testimony lter uh so
really quickly again just to ground
everybody uh the Southern New Hampshire
uh Regional water uh connection project
or the phase one part of that again is
moving water from Manchester Waterworks
as a participant through da a portion of
Windam uh with pachuk uh Waterworks uh s
uh in Hampstead area water company uh
with
ainson uh going into plastow that
initial phase was for roughly a million
gallons a day uh that was funded
primarily through the drinking water
groundwater trust fund the communities
themselves uh and in a lot of in kind
work with the communities so you know
Salem's a good example uh you know they
were actually doing a lot of managing a
lot of that work uh to to have the the
the upsizing the pipes and and uh put
new pipes in uh and again going with a
franchise into uh Windom uh the project
as mentioned phase one was sized for for
a future flow we had identified before
we started what the long-term needs were
for that area of over 3 million gallons
per day uh we we approached this with
what's what I would call a no regrets
policy so what we did not want to see is
during phase one we put pipe in and then
a couple years later we're digging it up
again uh so we you know we intentionally
I think we're being smart to to
economize as much as we can um
the some some questions regarding phase
uh regarding
pasas uh obviously last week EPA
announced new more stringent standards
than we currently have in the State uh
that puts that whole area of the state
uh in Jeopardy because a lot of Water
Supplies are now not not going to meet
that standard so that was envisioned uh
we weren't always on the same page as
EPA to be blunt but they were signaling
four parts per trillion for a long time
so as far as water needs there was the
General ask to these communities what do
you think you need in the future and
with added with our G we we we can see
that you're going to need more because
of your water supplies are
contaminated uh so so there's a couple
aspects to what's talked about and I'm
I'm talking now to Senator abb's uh
proposed amendment uh and that's
important because we were asked in the
Senate I'm providing information to be
blunt the Department's not taking a
position on this but we we do think it
could be definitely would be
beneficial uh to the to the southern
part of the state is the the ask by
phasing it we were asking the Senate can
you phase this give us some information
to phase this uh we provided in what we
just handed out with with three phases
Senator abis uh referred to a b and c uh
so that so talking to that the the first
page of that handout indicates what we
would potentially do if we did a phased
approach and that would call for
notionally 7 million from General funds
and 6.5 million from a combination of
the trust fund and other federal funds
that we're trying to secure um so so to
answer some of those questions I'm hope
hopeful that that helps and what that
involves is basically debottlenecking
Upstream of many of the communities to
allow that greater flow so you know
things like
um addressing pumping addressing uh
storage tanks
addressing uh needs for the the
chemistry as as you increase the flow
and one of the other issues uh and we're
trying to trying to uh secure federal
funds for as part of that greater need
mostly
mostly because of past contamination is
U Lake Massa basic so we're trying to
secure federal funds uh to raise Lake
Mass ofic uh if if we raise it a foot
that's one of the storage one of the
primary uh feeds for for Manchester
Waterworks who's feeding this whole
system right now uh that would provide 1
billion cubic feet of water additionally
by raising that for for a foot uh that's
probably at least in my experience for a
couple million that's probably the best
bang for the buck we're going to get
anywhere so that's part of the project
where the Southern New Hampshire project
doesn't necessarily feed lonary raising
Lake Massabesic would secure more water
for Londoner who's very heavily impacted
by by uh past contamination so with that
I'm certainly here to answer questions
again we're not the Department's not
taking a position on where this money
should come from uh I would argue that
we have a good track record of putting
to the extent we do get money I think we
put the very good use in these projects
represent papich M thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for being here to testify
um I was looking through the handout
that was just distributed and one of the
things I noticed is that while most of
the pipeline new pipes would be laid in
der by providing a second path to Der
you would make you would be able to make
more water available to the communities
Downstream obviously again being from a
town that already purchased the rights
to a certain allocation does does that
mean that there will be a future
opportunity to reserve more you know
rights to water in the future as the
project gets completed and the
availability increases and if so what
would be the timeline so that I can let
my town know when to prepare to consider
such issues sure that's a great question
so so I'm gonna answer you and then my
experts going to correct me if I get
this wrong so so the allocation so what
the representative is talking about is
Manchester Waterworks has a has a
capacity fee so if you want to reserve
their capacity you make a payment and
effectively they use that to then get
more sources of water eventually uh and
and Windam has paid for a certain amount
my recollection is as we did this those
that msdc it's called for Manchester
what you purchased was assuming the 3.1
million of the buildout of phase two is
that correct Mike not quite not quite
all right I knew I wasn't going to get
there so um yeah Windam all the partners
have purchased the water rights for
phase one and then there is an agreement
in place called The Sia Southern
interconnect agreement that lays out the
allocations for phase two if and when
it's constructed and that would be the
time when the partners would have the
opportunity to purchase that additional
capacity so the timeline really depends
on the
funding if I may follow up follow up
very briefly assuming the funding goes
through as planned which is an
optimistic assumption always but let's
assume that what kind of timeline are we
looking at what's the most optimistic
timeline for those decisions to be to
have to be made by the towns can design
and constructions at least two years two
to three years so in that time frame and
and certainly the partners would convene
there's a board that meets on a somewhat
regular basis um that all of the towns
and water suppliers are part of and they
would definitely be convening that group
to start that discussion thank you can
we have that witness fill out a card
before you leave one of these pink cards
representative Edwards for question uh
thank you Mr chair so one of the towns I
represent is Auburn and Auburn basically
has Lake Massabesic surrounded and uh of
course the the lake belongs to the
Manchester Waterworks but as a as a
courtesy in the past it seems like
there's been really good coordination
between the the Waterworks and the town
of Auburn do do you know if um if anyone
has been talking to the Auburn selectman
or or would this be a surprise to them
if I were to talk to
them I can't answer that directly I
don't know what Communications has been
I know the only act activity right now
for Lake Massabesic is uh Manchester
Waterworks is under is going through a
study to to make sure to kind of nail
down if we were to do this or if they
were to do this to be blunt uh what
would that look like what would be the
cost uh so we have some notional costs
so and also easements and what would be
the impacts and you know so I would I
would trust and hope that Manchester
Waterworks if they have in the past
which I assume is communicated with the
community I don't know why they wouldn't
be doing that now but I I long answer to
say I don't know the answer if they've
communicated that yet all right thank
you
follow have followup okay and and and U
because um the residents of Auburn are
so protective and so concerned about
Lake Massabesic it's the center of our
town um uh anything that has to do with
that it gets to be um of of high
interest what what I had been told last
time I looked into this was that um uh
we had completed a water supply line
that fed from the the river and that our
uh uh need or ability to meet the needs
of the communities of Salem and
elsewhere were um more than more than
adequate for as far into the future as
we could
look is this I must have heard something
wrong because I I already thought that
we had a water supply secured for
anything we want to do in the Southern
Tier so the answer to that is yes and no
first of all we other think to your
earlier question the other thing we can
do certainly is the department can make
sure that we can request that Manchester
is is coordinating so we will certainly
do that uh I'm not sure I can make them
but I I'm can't imagine they wouldn't uh
and second of all so yes the the you're
talking the uh water withdrawal uh they
have a radial well they they
commissioned Manchester Waterworks
commissioned in hookit uh from the
meramac river and that was sized in
order to to make in because people like
Windam have bought that capacity that
was sized to meet that projected 3.1
million um for those communities what
we've seen since is uh communities like
uh again the past issue is really thrown
a Mikey wrench into a lot of this so we
have communities like londondary who
have a greater need than we expected uh
We've also commissioned study study in
the last year looking
at just general water needs going Beyond
those communities and again probably not
surprising we're finding the needs are
are are greater even than we expected so
this adding Lake Massabesic is is uh
does a couple things but one of them is
it provides a little bit more redundancy
uh again you're correct that that uh
withdrawal effectively from the meramac
does provide a lot more capacity for
Manchester Waterworks but what we're
finding is the trend is there's even
more demand for for good clean
water represent Heath for a question um
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um the Manchester of
Waterworks is I'm from Manchester I just
a former Alderman so I'm familiar with a
lot of this um and the work they're
doing is absolutely extraordinary my
question is kind of simple I just don't
understand how are you going to raise
Massabesic level a foot or raise what
how how are you going to do that it's
pretty full right now
correct and sometimes it gets there
anyways I think um so so they they use
dams to to control the water level and
it would be an upgrade to those dams and
then obviously you look at what happens
if you do
that represent Maguire for question
thank you Mr chairman thank you
commissioner a key consideration for our
committee is the source of funds and all
the paper I see in front of me is
extremely vague in that regard um the
fiscal note says drinking water and
groundwater trust fund which I assume
comes originally from uh um the general
fund or maybe it's revolving funds on
projects that get paid back I'm not sure
there's the P remediation loan and Grant
fund there's federal funds and local
contributions but there's no specifics
and then the one you just handed out is
an additional 7 million of General funds
so can you give us a better idea of
what's coming from
where uh I'll I'll attempt to do that
again I think it's it's it's so the the
trust fund just really quickly that was
monies that were obtained by the state
for mtbe lawsuits and the the monies
that were there two sets of monies but
in this case the monies went to the
state a certain amount went to the rainy
day fund and the rest went by Statute
you guys passed you all passed the law
to to establish the drinking water
groundwater trust fund so that's not
there's no back and forth between the
general fund and that uh just just to be
clear so that's a that that commission
is is a 17 I forget I'm on it uh 17 or
19 person commission that makes those
decisions uh for that um so for the
funding again my understanding and and
the senator would be better on the
answer I I I think you're talking about
a combination of funds because that
that's that's how we've done things so
there's not been an Ask yet to the trust
fund uh but being on the commission I
know there's just like you look for the
general fund gee there's not there's not
unlimited resources here and we need to
be careful how we spend it so again my
understanding was at least notionally uh
it was it was to be a total for this one
phase of 7 million in asked to general
fund was the ask but that that'd be a
better question for the senator and then
the the trust fund would make up um of
the
13.5 that you see in the handout on the
top block would likely uh be the the the
remainder of that and I know the trust
fund commission chair is is aware and
generally agreeable to that out with the
caveat that the whole trust fund needs
to commission needs to vote on that and
then as I mentioned the lake Massabesic
was another 3 million we're looking at
not General funds for that we were
looking at uh federal funds for that uh
we're still trying to arrange that and
then uh on our handout on the the next
block below not D not directly part of
providing the the extra flow but being
writing on that is a uh developer funded
project at the Hamstead area water
company for another four million so what
we've been trying to do just like for
the trust fund is leverage uh you know
other people's money if you will OPM uh
of to to get as much bang for the buck
as we can but this was the my
understanding that's the general fund
ask for that phase if that if that
helps thank you Mr chairman so um are
any of these structured as loans
because because often with water
projects they're they're like a loan
that gets paid back to the trust or to
to the fund when the water gets used by
the by the users and their fees for
water
yeah so I think so certainly the
appropriation you're talking about would
wouldn't be a loan if you were to do
that with the with the general fund the
trust fund
typically but not always is a
combination of uh grants and Loans are
are paid back so that' be a discussion
most likely though this would be a grant
from the trust fund uh in the as I
mentioned to the the federal money for
Lake Massabesic that would that would be
effectively a Grant and the developers
putting money in directly so that's he
may be taking out a loan to cover that
but that's effectively there so that's
short answer is most of that is
envisioned as as a
grant I have a question that uh a dozen
years I've been tracking this
P we seem to keep reducing 70 parts per
trillion eight parts per trillion four
parts per trillion when you go from
eight parts parts per trillion to four
parts per trillion you don't just double
the amount of money it's quite likely 10
times as much but yet I seen no human
testing to justify all this have you
seen
any as you're aware uh representative
you know the state you know my agency
did did promate a standard uh got it's
been a while now I forget how many years
seven years ago I think on on P and and
we were in the teen teens for four of
the components
uh and that was based on we had our own
uh we hired a toxicologist and a health
risk assessor and we work with h Health
and Human Services EPA standard
obviously they have their own science in
that to be blunt we weren't there we
would have put it at four if we thought
it should have been at four uh they have
but we did what we did with the best
science we had available at the time so
EPA believes they
have uh for pfos and pfoa I don't want
to get too t for everybody they believe
it's a likely carcinogen based on their
studies and their their experts that
drives the Clean Water Act to say you
need to make the standard as low as
economically
feasible uh you may have heard me
talking about that in the Press uh I was
on the front page of the union leader I
think the
costs collectively are are being
underestimated based on our experience
here in New Hampshire and that would
feed into that standard but short sure
is EPA feels that they have that that
data I haven't my people haven't said g
it should be four it needs to be before
if we had we would have changed our own
standard but again it's a much larger
agency the EPA than than we are but
again no human studies to support that
number sure that um that's what I'm
aware of I I understand what you're
saying there there is some they did use
again I don't want to get too wonky here
for the for everybody there's some
studies that EPA is is human studies
that they are now quoting in Pharaoh
Islands uh and different things like
that again that's not data that we used
I would think that before we spend
multi-billions trying to get down to
four parts per trillion that we ought to
spend a few million doing human studies
and that so I think it's the tail
wagging the dog and and we're getting
ahead of ourselves finally we're
spending some money in maram that's the
first human study I've heard of and you
know and we ought to be doing widespread
testing among the population to see what
each of us has already for parts per
trillion in New Hampshire there there is
uh there has been uh blood testing at
around the P Air Force base area also
have you got the results published
anywhere uh heal Health un Services has
that information thank you further
questions representative
hle thank you Mr chair in addition to
the ch change of capacity at Massabesic
lake is there any other large um
capacity storage facilities invisioned
in the plan so so there is daily draw
limits right but Having excess capacity
is what mitigates the days where there's
peaks in terms of draw and I wasn't sure
besides Massabesic Lake does the plan
include anything else in terms of bulk
storage Mike if you
want
so few of the systems da uh say
have ainson have existing storage and
then as part of phase two there's one
proposed storage tank uh and dairy that
would be the only
additional follow up follow up so of
those that are currently in use where is
the capacity level typically at and are
we fully use utilizing those now or
not um so the biggest one well
Manchester has 5 million gallons of
storage in London Dairy and then Dairy
has four in their main service Zone
Salem has I think 4 million gallons and
the way they're fully utilized they
always fill those tanks to the top and
it's really an operational decision uh
during High usage days they'll draw the
tanks down farther than on
average all right we've got one more
witness members uh finish this up thank
thank you gentlemen U we have Roy
Sorenson from
Salem that's for the next
one good good afternoon everyone my name
is Roy senson I'm with the town of Salem
I'm also here representing the uh
Southern New Hampshire Regional water
Partners um Mike Anger from Das
mentioned that that's the group he was
talking about and those are the folks
that are uh Affiliated through the sea
which is the southern interconnection
agreement which was the the premise of
this project from uh the beginning back
in 2017 18 uh he had to testify on a
couple things so this project itself is
unprecedented when you look at the
relationships between the
communities and our relationships with
the private water suppliers that would
be the penu of the world the Manchester
Waterworks and the uh Hamstead area
water company
hawc uh we also uh service a section of
Windom we took a section of Windom as
our franchise area so the town of Salem
actually controls and services that
section of Windham I don't believe that
is the case anywhere else in the state
as far as a public water supplier uh
servicing another community so we talked
a about a lot of things here today we
talked about capacity I'll just come
back to the question on capacity storage
wise in Salem we have on hand any day 5
million gallons that's in our water
tanks that's our additional storage
capacity the question becomes the
overall capacity of our current water
supplies canaby Lake and Arlington Pond
and that's why we entered into this um
project in the first place because we
had capacity issues and we also had
contamination issues at the time the
spirit of that project was based on MTB
contamination since that time mtb's kind
of taking a back seat and now posos and
P or I should say p and then in
particular POA and uh P fos pfos have
taken uh the primary seat the Southern
Tier itself as as you've heard today is
growing uh we obviously are keen on that
and we keep an eye on that uh we also
have demand that we're looking at
throughout that southern portion or that
southern part of the state which we
looked at initially through the studies
the overall capacity was 3.13 for that
project uh to date roughly 1 million as
commissioner Scott said is coming over
the dairy line and and that that is
built the issue we're having right now
is the ability to pump more through the
system to get us to that
3.13 the communities have bought in by
purchasing their water rights Salem
itself we had a warrant article four or
five years back where we uh levied $5
million uh of public money to buy our
water rights from Manchester so um I'm
here to say that this is a unprecedented
project in the beginning if you asked me
10 years ago if this was even plausible
I would say absolutely abolutely not so
what is the benefit of that right now I
think you have needs throughout the
state and you're going to see a lot of
contamination and if you're going to
continue to follow this model this is a
model project to these other communities
to say this can be done you can have
Public Water Supplies you can have
private Water Supplies you can enter
into uh agreements including
intermunicipal agreements an example we
have three different agreements we're in
right now whether it's with penchuk with
the town of Windham and the southern
inter interconnection agreement
so um I'm here to say that again when
you when you look at the need and the
funding to put forward for this and to
finish this project off it's certainly
going to benefit uh the Southern Tier
and it sets the model for the rest of
the state thank you representative f for
a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question so why would this
not be considered as part of the next
capital budget so that it could be cons
state's capital budget so that it could
be considered in light of all the other
needs Capital needs of the state um I
thank you for the question
representative I can't I'm not I'm not I
can't answer that question I mean that
would be a question for either uh
Senator
abbis any other questions from the
committee
members represent papichi Muller thank
you Mr chair not a question really just
a quick comment I just wanted to um
thank the town of Salem you know for
having the flexibility to accommodate
wiam because that was a win-win and you
know I wish we would see more situations
in the state where towns would work
together like that because both of them
benefited from the agreement but being
unprecedented I did want to express my
appreciation for the willingness of uh
the town of Salem to consider that
agreement yeah thank you absolutely so
yeah we did and part of that was the
inter Municipal I spoken with him at
some meetings as well um and you have
some really good leadership over over
there right now your Town Administrator
Brian mccy and and and looking forward
so thank
you any further questions for the
witness seeing none I'll read the uh
sign up sheet for Senate Bill
393 Katherine Heck from nhma is in favor
uh Joe dine it looks like from Salem in
favor uh Roy senson who's before us in
favor uh Fred Wallace Salem in favor and
like Doug Allen from Salem also in
favor that is the list now we'll begin
on Senate Bill
393 relative to making 396 three sorry
the on the last one we just finished
396 relative to making an appropriation
to the culinary arts program at the wi
Wilbur H Palmer Regional Career and
Technical education center I'll call on
the sponsor Senator Carson welcome to
house finance senator
good morning Mr chairman and good
morning honorable members of the house
finance committee I have for your cons
uh for the record my name is Sharon
Carson and I have the pleasure to
represent Senate District 14 comprising
the towns of londonairy Hudson and
Auburn and I have for your consideration
this morning Senate Bill
396 which seeks to make an appropriation
from the education trust fund to the
Department of Education to fund the
repair and replacement of the
ventilation an exhaust fan system for
the teaching kitchen at the culinary
arts program at the Wilbur AG Palmer
Regional Center and Technical education
center at alurn High School in Hudson um
Mr chairman um these funds will enable
the Palmer Career and Technical
education center to repair and replace
ventilation and exhaust um systems in
the culinary arts programs teaching
system um I'd also like to say that
there has been
a I guess um it would best to be called
it some sort of mixup and
miscommunication between uh the school
district in Hudson and the Department of
Education a few years ago we had
authorized um the financing of a new CTE
Center at HUD at alurn high school and
there was some money left over
approximately between 600 and $700,000
um the school district made the request
of the Department of Education not once
but twice if they could spend that money
on getting these new hoods and the
Department of Education told them yes
you can use that money so they went
ahead and they spent the money and they
got the new hoods and installed them but
in the meantime the state went and
clawed it
back so now um they have these hoods
they had had expected to use the
leftover money um it was not a line item
in the budget and they were given um
some bad
information and so now what we're
looking to do is to make the town of
Hudson whole um this was a mistake on
the part of the Department of Education
and it should not fall on the taxpayers
of Hudson to make up that difference
because that's if you choose not to do
that that's exactly what's going to
happen because the vendor of course
needs to be
paid um and I just like to add a couple
more things the repair and the
replacement will provide a learning
space for students to prepare for
careers in the hospitality and
restaurant industry and I hope all of
you have the opportunity to go to uh
their in school restaurant a lot of
events are held there the students do a
fabulous job and many of them leave and
they will go on to a culinary Arts
Advanced program and they're working in
our state's
restaurants
um in its present State the students can
observe a teacher demonstrating but not
really some of those essential skills
the appropriation will allow them to
become skilled and knowledgeable and
good paying jobs and I'm just going to
leave that here I'm hoping that um that
the finance committee can support this
and rectify I'm mistake that was made um
to the school district in Hudson and I
believe there are folks here who could
probably give you a lot more detail than
I can so I appreciate your time this
morning and all your efforts thank you
very much questions from the senator
seeing none appreciate you being here so
will next call on Jeff beard from the
Department of Education
thank you Mr chair members of the uh
committee Representatives uh for the
record I'm Jeff beard I'm the state
director for Career and Technical
education with the Department of
Education and with me Melissa white
Melissa white division director for
learner support department of education
and we would ask that you fill out a
pink card after you finish thank you
welcome thank you um so if if it uh
please the committee and uh Mr chair I'm
available to answer any questions around
uh the bill um and I can provide
background and context uh if you'd like
to lead with questions um that might be
a good way to proceed or I can provide a
quick
overview representative Maguire for a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for coming I was a little unclear from
Senator Carson's testimony as to whether
this project is already complete already
in in use and therefore this is just
paying due to the mistake and how it was
going to be paid or is if we ex allocate
These funds then the project can go
forward superintendent mulis from Hudson
is here he can provide a little more
detail when he speaks but I I believe
that it is has been completed and that
the uh the vendor is asking for invoices
to be paid at this point Thank follow up
is this um facility only used by
students in um HUD from Hudson or from
many other places I'm so glad you asked
representative um Career Technical
education programs in this across the
state are Regional in nature uh Hudson
has um students that are coming from um
the Milford area the emerest area um the
uh London are Manchester uh there are
students coming from all over the region
uh for CTE at at Hudson um so it really
serves above and beyond uh just the
students that are at Al High School
another thing that I will always uh
whenever I'm given an opportunity to to
speak CTE is a powerful uh economic uh
driver for our state uh Career and
Technical education students are skilled
and knowledgeable they're the next
generation of workers and small business
owners uh in the state so whenever we
think about the regional nature of CT I
think it's important to keep that in
mind that it also is a really powerful
economic uh engine for all the regions
of the state
I believe there's 16
CTE uh representative wer at this uh
point there are 28 28 yep going from the
the southern part of the state all the
way up to C Brook yeah and these are all
Partnerships between the department of
Ed and the local community that hosts
them correct they're eligible to take in
students from all around and every two
years in the capital budget there's a
definite appropriation to ensure that at
least two CTE get some money every every
time there's a rotation so thank you we
appr something we've worked on in this
committee did you have a followup I did
one so when a student comes from another
District does money come with the
student or and and to what ex how many
students are we talking about and to
what fraction is are they state
funded uh great question so the uh the
the State covers 75% of tuition uh for
regional CTE students so the the
receiving high school or the CTE Center
will charge a uh a tuition uh to the
sending high school students uh then the
department uh does an annual payment
every December that covers 75% of that
cost this is the line that's see Comm
tuition and transportation in the school
budget this is what covers for the CTE
and students coming from surrounding
towns did you want to say
further represent Heath thank you Mr
chair um my question is about the
process um normally the CTE is an kind
of like a queue um just as uh the chair
described and the money comes from the
capital budget and um the project goes
on now what I'm what I think I heard
from the senator is that that's how the
project was funded but there was a
remaining amount of money that was left
and for that Alver was told that they
could go forward and then the department
of Ed reneged is that true uh I can give
a little bit more context so the uh the
miscommunication that Senator Carson
referred to that did come out of my
office uh that is something that I will
will own and take responsibility for um
a former employee was asked will these
funds be available um her
interpretation of that question was
should they be brought forward they
would be available the the funds of
course as you all well know are not
available until the budget is is enacted
uh so when when she heard that question
what she heard was These funds will be
available if uh and that was
misunderstood on the other end so um
strictly speaking the department did not
clawback the funds the department there
was some funds were unexpended the
department uh chose to not bring those
forward and return them uh to the
state now this money was budgeted for
Elburn the funds there were remaining
funds and this local Center was told by
someone at the department that they were
approved and they went ahead and they
did the
project and it was money that had had
been budgeted for them originally am I
correct to a certain extent the the yes
or no
please yes but not for the purpose of of
this uh specific
item so to clarify the funds were going
to be spent after the fiscal year we
didn't feel like we had the authority to
go ahead and approve that and so the
commissioner had said no we will not be
bringing those funds forward and I think
that that was the misunderstanding that
was communicated by uh one of our
staff followup but this was past the
process to approve an extension correct
was Alver alerted to the need to do that
correct yes and did they follow through
that's where the miscommunication
because they felt that they had
communicated it to our office and our
office felt that they had communicated
that it would not be going forward that
we were not requesting that
extension th alleg ative
fix I understand the frustration and we
are working to or we have corrected
those internal processes and procedures
to make sure going forward that nothing
like this happens again representative
Petri for a question yeah thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
question
um how come this wasn't part of the
original proposal you know to do I mean
hoods is is a normal part of culinary
arts thank you for the question that's a
great question
the Ser the additional Services were
outside of the scope of the original
project and I'll just add this is a
really in the weed so forgive me I won't
go too too far into it there are two uh
separate sections in the colonary arts
program space uh at at the Palmer Center
there is a commercial kitchen which uh
serves the restaurant that commercial
kitchen has adequate ventilation there's
also a teaching kitchen the teaching
kitchen has a set of induction cook
service so that the teacher can
demonstrate cooking techniques students
can then uh mirror those techniques
that's the area that was lacking proper
ventilation so if they were ever going
to use oil um shortening any kind of
thing that needed ventilation they
wouldn't be able to they would only be
able to do chopping um boiling things of
that nature but no sauting or brazing
or some other really essential
techniques represented string for a
question and repres
Edwards uh yes thank you for taking my
question uh so uh given that this this
money uh has been authorized and and
spent but I guess not paid uh assuming
the state uh doesn't and Department of
Ed doesn't come in am I correct to
assume that the Hudson property
taxpayers or local taxpayers are going
to have to come up with this money or is
it going to be subject to a court case
or you know where are we going if if we
don't uh uh come up with some time based
payment to pay
this if you know thank you for the
question I think that um that might be
something we would want to talk with
Hudson a little bit more uh in depth
about representative Edwards for a
question yeah thank you there there are
other members of this committee that
have uh have sat on the finance or the
education subcommittee finance and
they're they're more expert at this I
I'm just telling you my my reaction to
this is that um if there wasn't a a
clear paper trail on the questions and
the approvals and the
decisions uh and the spending decision
was made without clear
documentation I I would hope and I don't
want to get into it in a public hearing
whever really but I would just want to
know that from a personnel management
perspective it's good to hear the
processes have been cleaned up but I'd
like to know that there was some
accountability because this doesn't
sound
right thank you for your comment yes it
has been handled thank
you anyone else representative papichi
M thank you Mr chair and thank you for U
providing details first let me uh remind
you that this is a committee that loves
weeds so don't hesitate to get in the
weed it's our job to you know go all the
way down there and I'm just trying to
summarize what happened just to make
sure I understood it correctly and I
would appreciate it if you would correct
any misunderstanding I may have that the
original project scope was completed
there was money left over then we had
that cross communication where people
misunderstood each other or basically
there was a misunderstanding between the
doe and Hudson as a result of which
Hudson in good faith proceeded to
complete the project and you know foot
the bills with a full expectation they
will be repaid by the doe but because of
the miscommunication do we found
themselves without the Appropriations to
refund them and this is why this bill is
fulfilled to write that wrong do I
understand everything correctly I'm just
correct thank you I just honestly there
are a lot of moving parts and I don't
want to get something wrong thank
you committee are we ready to hear from
the superintendent
there's no further questions for these
people and we'll hear from Dr Daniel
Mullis thank you for
coming good morning thank you for having
me here uh so again I'm just going to
provide some brief uh brief remarks uh
Mr Mr popovic Mueller good to see you
again long time from my time in window I
was going to say hello later
but and Miss Heath I know you as well so
good to see you um again I want to thank
Senator Carson for uh sponsoring this uh
Senate Bill 396
fn- um I want to speak to the importance
of the allocation of
the culinary arts program in classroom
um to be clear there was a question on
this side of the room as far as uh have
these these expenditures these bills
been paid um we did have to pay those
bills the vendor expected the work to be
done uh the work was well underway um by
the time we were notified um that that
work had already started um so for the
record I did want to clarify that the
project was well under construction well
underway when we we were notified of
that um again uh you know I think
working with the Department of Education
um we're just looking to uh make sure
that that's not going to be paid from
local property taxes and and uh just
correct that but we as a district did
have to pay for pay for that bill um to
to the vendor um as mentioned the
specialized ventilation program by Mr
beard is on the classroom side of the
culinary arts um it is specifically for
uh specialized cooking so such as grease
cooking um for the students and as
mentioned by Senator Carson um that
helps support students going into
multiple different fields in The
Culinary in The Culinary and hospitality
industry um so that is why those uh
those uh specific hoods are needed from
a ventilation standpoint and also from a
fire safety fire code standpoint um so
that is that is why that that was that
was needed uh I'm going to pause there
um to see if there's questions from the
committee
any questions from the
committee representative Maguire thank
you Mr chairman thanks for coming
superintendent how many uh cook stations
are there in this
classroom all right I'm going to
estimate it I don't have the exact
number right in front of me and I would
be more than willing to follow up on
that I believe there are at a minimum I
want to say 12 or 14 but I I want to I
can get you a specific number but at a
minimum there's 14 what happens is
students work at those cooking stations
there'll be multiple State uh students
working at that station but they they
try to minimize at least two two to
three students per station follow up
thank you do you think it's a wise use
of public funds to spend
$50,000 per cook station for something
that's being used relatively
infrequently well we do have um uh
multiple classes for The Culinary and as
mentioned uh it's not just one class um
and we also have students from Hudson
but also as believe has mentioned Mr
Maguire in one of your comments
surrounding school districts also are
part of our Career Technical education
center for regional for the region um
that were in um and most of those were
mentioned but I I'd be remissed to say
that one of those that wasn't mentioned
was also Lichfield so Lichfield marac
London der uh we do have some students
from NASA Milford um and surrounding
communities that utilize that so it's
it's multiple classes not just one class
per
day follow thank you
so you know I I took such a class when I
was in Middle School so I I sort of
appreciate it but it it just seems like
like a
ridiculously large amount of money per
student
um now one other question we heard that
in general the state pays three4 of the
costs of these programs would it make
sense then for the state to pay three4
of this
cost again that's uh that's based upon I
believe the how the formula Works um and
again I would defer to the Department of
Education they would understand that
much more so uh than myself um to your
other comment though Mr Maguire uh we do
have other programs such as our welding
program and uh engine repair program
large uh auto automotive um there's a
lot of equipment a lot of teaching
equipment that is needed in those
programs uh that are are costly um and I
my question with a question back would
be
I I would hope that this
committee uh would would support
students that are entering multiple
different career Pathways uh going
forward and and recognizing that yes
some of those programs do cost a bit of
money uh for students to access those
trades in those career
paths represent papich M thank you Mr
chair and nice seeing you Mr Mullis
after quite a few years um I will start
by instead of asking a question just
saying that I uh love seeing your career
growth and I wish uh the district would
have been able to retain your services
but we were not you know able to and uh
you know it's our loss but in terms of
this particular question what's the
expected uh you know lifetime of this
equipment yeah great question um at a
minimum it would be at a minimum I would
say 20 to 25 years and they could last
longer again um with any any facilities
project I think back to our time in
Windom with the preventative maintenance
making sure you do the the PM work on
those systems they can last well beyond
20 25 years if you look at ventilation
systems at a minimum you can get a good
20 25 years I remember in my time in
Windom we had ventilation systems were
were a bit older and uh with the proper
preventative maintenance they can extend
that life and uh just uh one quick
followup would you say that a
significant reason of why these items
are so expensive is that there are a lot
of code and safety regulations that
require certain capabilities of the
equipment that is correct sir yes thank
you you're welcome
okay hack and Phillips thank you Mr
chair and thank you Mr Mullis is that
right y um for taking my question um we
heard a lot from the Department of
Education about the you know process
miscommunication and their efforts to
resolve that moving forward um I'm just
wondering if Hudson's district has also
done an internal review of um their
administrative processes and try to
prevent this kind of miscommunication
again in the future well uh to speak
very frankly um we had emails and
correspondents that showed that we could
move forward with that process I I do
not believe anyone in our district uh
misinterpreted that or misconstrued that
um again I do think to Mr Mr Beard's
Point um Miss White's point there was a
miscommunication but we had every reason
to believe to move forward and from an
internal standpoint I I don't believe
the district has done anything wrong we
move forward based upon the information
we
had further from the
committee there being none we'll close
the hearing and I have the sign up sheet
and only contains Dr mullis's signature
in favor so that's thank you that's all
we have in this commit comme I believe
it'll be scheduled in division two when
they get a chance after this I'd like to
we're going to have a a uh a recess
until one o'clock but I'd like to have a
quick meeting with the three division
chairs so we can talk about what we want
to set up for um schedule for the next
week because the deadline is at about
one o'cl today so if you want to
schedule something for next week
probably division one might be the only
one that has an division two is already
scheduled for 11:00 next Tuesday next
Tuesday 11 thank you and in division 3
uh went ahead and said an end to Janet
that we would meet on the 23rd and the
30th at 1:00 and that's a joint with
division two and and the chair and I
have agreed very good join Peter have
you already said
something
may very good you're May
7th very good all right we'll be in
recess till 1 o'
you
want
e
e e
order and at 1 o' we are scheduled to
hear Senate Bill 453 I'll call on the
prime spon sponsor Senator
gray thank you uh my name is James Gray
I repres present Senate District 6 which
starts up in Alton and gilon comes down
Route 11 to the great City of Rochester
and we don't want to miss Farmington you
know you don't want to mess they don't
want all mess with them and miss them so
uh this bill uh
certainly
uh it is to ensure that the efforts that
the secretary of state is doing to
update the database uh provides for the
things that we do um many many many
constituents tell me how hard it is to
get to the town clerk how hard it is to
be able to actually sit and meet with
them and that they don't understand the
process who do I go to when I want to
change my party affiliation who do I go
to when now I'm I'm recently married and
I you know my name has changed and I
want to do that and I've moved and all
of this other thing
well a lot of that
information yeah you can do it on
Election Day uh but sometimes it makes
it more difficult uh especially if
you've moved uh because right now if
you've recently moved and you go to the
town clerk and they can log into the
database and they can see you're
previously registered you don't have to
prove age you don't have to prove
citizenship what you need to prove is
domicile and of course any of those
proofs you need to prove identity along
the way so the original bills that have
been in here for the last two or three
years uh in the house and in the Senate
um specified all of the rsas that it
didn't change and those are the ones
that require a person who is registering
to vote to meet with the supervisor the
checklist or the so all of that is
already really really in statute and all
of the emails that I got when I got your
house bill back on the portal that said
oh this is going to allow people just to
go register that's not the not the case
and in the Senate I can tell you I will
be writing an amendment to the house
bill that came over uh that will specify
that they can't complete the
registration process without you know
presenting their documents to either the
clerk or or to the supervisor of the
checklist uh it will go in and specify
that the portal will have to have
certain fields in there and among those
fields will be the last four digits of
the social security number and the
driver's license number voter ID number
or a box that says I don't have either
one okay and again um in a different
Bill probably I'm actually going to go
in and and specify that those are
mandatory fields for registering okay
again trying to get us closer to the
situation where you know uh people can
go in and take care of as much of this
and then just either have to drop the
document off and say hey I am who I am
here's my license uh there's no reason
why a person if there's a long line to
register on Election Day that if they
could go into the portal and the portal
say Hey you know your number is
ab123 and you go up and say hey I just
logged in I'm
ab123 and then the person look at that
look at the online not have to fill out
any more forms except for something that
just says you know you provided your
documentation sign here that all the
stuff is accurate so again we can get
there and people
now especially the younger Generations
younger than I sh will say uh you know
are expecting some of these things to be
on online but we're not going to
sacrifice our security of the system
we're not going to sacrifice the other
things but we want to give them place if
you want to change your voter
registration you know your your address
your name
whatever log on here and what'll happen
is the system will take that information
and it will provide it to the clerk and
to the supervisor of the checklist as
appropriate and for that information now
change of address okay right now the uh
change of address database that the post
office has uh the permanent change of
address if I've got that and I've got
the person coming in saying this is my
change of address is that sufficient
well that's a question we need to answer
if I've got a marriage record you know
you come in and you say yeah I recently
got married oh where did you get married
I got married in New Hampshire you know
what the clerks have got those records
they've got all the vital records they
can go look you up okay uh again so
there's a lot of things that we can do
and have actual records and documents to
allow this process to go through and go
through smoothly we just need to make
sure that the
database in the upgrades that we're
doing to it are properly funded I do
know that one of our our Representatives
asked about the difference between 550
million ion and 450 million uh thousand
excuse me excuse me I I I you know I
just came from fiscal you know and we
we've been talking big big numbers so
anyway and the thousands excuse my my my
misspeak uh but uh one of the uh the
Senators um uh has uh convinced the
secretary of state that he can use uh
some other funds uh to pay for that that
extra 100,000 and again this is
not there there are other changes in the
database that you and I want uh and we
also need to make sure that whatever we
do that proper training is given to
these officials so that they can
understand what they can do uh and again
I don't believe that the statute has to
change uh but because you've sent me a
bill that specifies certain things on
the portal uh I am going to update that
as I should say I'm going to write the
amendment to update it and I believe it
will pass the Senate to come back to you
uh to make sure that we do maintain
Integrity we do maintain uh control over
that database and that people uh who are
registering have
presented uh in accordance with the
existing statute uh remember that right
now you can do all those things that we
talked about in the portal you can send
them an email you can write them a
letter okay you can do all of those
things by other means the portal just
gives them that one place and you say
hey go to NH dot dot dot and you can
start the process and then they will
converse with you either by email or
whatever and uh right now the only place
that you can actually go with without
showing your documentation is if you're
an absentee voter and you don't have
time to register before the election um
and that's the only time and certainly
in that I also want to add in in their
request they will also need to put in
the last four digits of the social
security number and either driver's
license uh voter a non-driver ID or
check a box that said they don't have
either uh so again we're we're trying to
make all of these things match up one
problem I heard in the last
election is same day registrant yep 20
of them use an address that was an empty
lot would this have caught that um I'm
addressing that in a different way I had
a meeting in my office yesterday with
the Attorney General's office and their
investigator uh Mr Tracy uh and the
Secretary of State and what we're
looking at is taking that investigating
part and moving it to election day
creating a group that can sit there uh
right now uh Mr Tracy says that he has
access to the TransUnion database and if
any of your familiar TransUnion is one
of the three major credit uh
organizations and in that database they
have lots of information so if I type in
we'll say uh you know Jess Edwards uh
okay and I say uh that he was born on
this day okay um and then an added bodus
would be the last four digits of the
social security number I can pretty much
confirm that Jess Edwards does live at a
particular place it will give me at
least a a previous address if not the
current address uh because of moving but
then remember I also have access um
through the uh permanent change of
address database from the United States
post office and we're also looking at
what information that I can get from the
Social Security again so so this is not
done in a vacuum okay we need to make
sure that each one of these parts of the
law you know can uh request the same
information and uh that we consistently
do it and that when I once I provided
that information through one of these
things that I've copied that information
into the database in the the proper
fields which already exist the proper
Fields they're just optional right now
instead of being
mandatory would you take any
questions I'm here for you
representative Stringham for a question
yeah thank you for your testimony and
thanks for taking my question uh this
bill seems to principally deal with an
appropriation for the Statewide voter
registration system uh without really
talking about where the appropriation
other than being directed in that
direction uh is um
uh is to be used but um uh I'm kind of
curious why uh you know this kind of
Standalone Financial bill is required
now in the middle of the bium rather
than being included in the budget what
has changed uh to require a special
appropriation outside of cycle well the
Senate did include it in there and then
there was a meeting uh between certain
factions both in the house and the
Senate uh that decided to take it out of
the budget at that time uh and uh there
were other things that were going on uh
there was legislation in the house that
uh uh certainly we would like to have
seen passed that didn't pass uh and all
of those things come together uh but
right now uh the reason that I want to
push it Forward is because they are
right now uh updating that database and
the secretary's office I'm sure will
talk talk more about that uh but uh the
sooner I can get that and the more you
know I can get it combined together with
the other things that you're doing uh I
don't know you know I I did some
programming when I was an engineer down
at the ports Naval Shipyard and The
Closer I Get get to the time that I
actually wrote the code in the beginning
the quicker it was for me to modify it
because you know I'd forget this and I'd
forget that and then that wouldn't work
right you know so again you getting this
stuff getting it into the database
getting it all you know is the reason to
push it Forward um and it's not that it
wasn't considered last time uh there
were things that were agreed to uh that
didn't happen and therefore the funding
was taken out of the the the bill the
last time uh as you remember that the
bill that you sent to the house finance
uh that uh as chair of Finance we cut
million do and I did get the million
right that time representative H uh out
of that budget and and you guys passed
it with an overwhelming majority thank
you questions represent tki thank you Mr
chairman thank you senator for taking my
question um I apologize I entered while
you were um presenting the bill however
you made a comment that I think I heard
correctly that there was some discussion
um in Senate election law about using
alternative funds I assume
you were referring to Hava funds or am I
mistaken on that and did that go
anywhere with an amendment uh because
the bill doesn't specify where the
secretary gets the money from uh he has
money that is um possibly Hava money you
know possibly other funds so where he
takes the money from um is not one of
the decisions I have to make and
certainly when he comes up to testify or
the deputy comes up to testify um he or
she can can Enlighten you more on that
uh but again you know it's they have an
an appropriation okay and the way they
spend that appropriation and the way
they spend Hava money is all controlled
by other things and so if I were to say
he's going to take it out of Hava I
could be wrong because he may take it
out of a different uh account that he
doesn't need that money in or he may may
take it out of hav money again it's not
not anything we need to control thank
you I just wanted to clarify that it
what there was no discussion of an
amendment for it thank you very much
yeah further questions from committee
members seeing none thank you Senator I
would like to stay but I've understood
needed across the
street then we'll next hear from the
Secretary of State Mr David scan
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm David scandin Secretary of
State and I'm here in support uh of this
bill um over the last two years uh my
office has been very aggressively
upgrading the electronic systems that we
have really across the department but
specifically elections related systems
and last week we had our new campaign
Finance system uh go online
uh we had the help of some of you and
other members of the legislature testing
that system out to make sure that it was
going to be functional and and you know
work well and it was a successful roll
out and uh looks like it's going to work
well for the upcoming election uh in the
next two weeks uh we plan to roll out
the uh brand new voter registration
database which is going to replace the
20 plus year old Legacy system and uh
you know we expect that that is going to
uh have a lot of functionality and be a
major Improvement to our local election
officials who are actually the ones that
put the information into the database
supervisors of the checklist are the
only ones that can remove names uh from
the voter checklist and you know it's
our hope that uh we will save them quite
a bit of
time in doing their jobs uh the bow law
Commission after a fairly lengthy uh
review and testing process has approved
two new electronic ballot counting
devices uh one has met the uh the
conditional approval and and the
certification requirements a company
called voting Works which uses open-
Source software code uh uh in the
programming of that device uh that was
used in five towns during the local
elections this past March
and we expect expanded use with that
device for the upcoming fall elections
the second device is one that's
manufactured by Dominion a name that I'm
sure all of you have heard uh the
certification is not expected on that
until sometime this fall which puts it
beyond the ability to use for the fall
elections but most likely will be
available for Town elections in the
spring and then the
uh at least once a week we're getting
requests from towns to be to be approved
for the use of electronic Pole books um
which is a way to keep track of
check-ins and uh and collecting the data
needed to file the return of votes at
the end of the day uh they still have to
do it in parallel with a paper checklist
but it is saving the local election
officials a tremendous amount of time uh
in terms of V voters being able to check
in getting results uh that they need to
report at the end of the night and then
the transfer of the electronic data they
that they collected directly into the
Statewide voter
database so this bill uh calling for a
voter portal is uh is timely uh
especially because of the new voter
registration database I'm not going to
repeat the testimony of Senator gray but
I would just add uh a couple of items on
that first uh I was clear from the
beginning in terms of a voter portal
that the only way that I would support
it if it maintains the
current processes uh and statutory
requirements for a voter registering to
vote which means that a voter has to
provide
uh information showing their
qualifications of age identity domicile
and citizenship
uh and that when they show up either for
the first time to vote on Election Day
or they make a visit to the clerk's
office they have to sign the voter
registration form and show their
documentation whether it's an actual
document or uh a an affidavit that is
currently allowed uh for them to
participate the advantage that I see is
that this will really help local
election officials uh especially
supervisors of the checklist who now
have to take data that is sometimes not
legibly written on voter registration
application forms and then having to
read that and then hand key it into the
uh voter database which creates the
checklist is certainly prone to error
and to the extent that we now have the
voters have the ability to provide that
data already uh typed out on the form
it's an electronic format so that the
supervisors can review it they can
approve it after they get all the
signatures and the documentation and
then they can simply transfer that
electronic data uh to the voter
registration database which means that
overall our the data in the database is
going to be much cleaner than it has
been uh uh before so uh those are the
significant improvements that I see uh
because of
this um in terms of the funding uh the
original appropriation was
$550,000 uh in the Senate I committed to
the committee that we could use $100,000
in Hava funds uh to help cover the cost
of that um and so the appropriation as
amended now is
$450,000 with that Mr chairman I'd be
happy to answer any questions thank you
questions from committee members
represent representative Edwards uh
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
secretary I I I know how important
election Integrity is to you and and I
and and I hear what you're saying from
the perspective of this is going to make
uh all of our U Town
functionaries more productive and have
less errors I get all of that but uh I
think you've heard and felt the concerns
in the state over uh election integrity
and the fear that this is going to be
just a a portal into online registration
and so if you could could you just make
the best succinct argument you can why
this is going to actually improve
election Integrity if if there is an
argument for that and and maybe the flip
side of it from an academic perspective
what are your greatest concerns
regarding election Integrity with this
system in place
the benefit is going to be the ability
to have more accurate data going into
the voter registration database itself
so that we don't have the clerical
errors that are made by volunteers who
are taking hundreds and thousands of
voter registration
applications uh that are handwritten uh
currently and then having to read that
and then uh enter that data
manually into the voter registration
database to the extent that it's the
voter providing the data and the
expectation is that you know it would be
accurate in the first
instance uh there would be no changes
along the way you know from that data
going from point A uh into the database
eventually New Hampshire is unique among
the states and and our systems are very
different than most every other state in
the country I'm sure all of you have
heard of Motor Voter and the national
voter registration act uh of 1992 or
um that system allowed for uh actually
required uh state
agencies uh focusing on Motor Vehicles
to collect a voter Reg
ations uh and uh you know and and enter
voters into the system in addition to
motor vehicles uh Departments of
Education Departments of Health and
Human
Services uh or agencies where there is
public
Outreach uh where uh federal government
requires that you know those be voter
registration
agencies any member of the public in one
of these states with Motor Voter can
walk down the street and collect voter
registrations simply by having
individuals fill out registration cards
and you may have heard of a situation
with a organization called Acorn some
years ago uh who were they were paid to
go out and collect signatures and
because of the money involved I mean
some of the sign some of the collections
were not
actual individuals they were just filled
out to collect the money um and so real
problems with
that what is special with New Hampshire
is that a voter has to appear before a
local election official somebody from
their Community one of their neighbors
to apply for uh being a voter um and
they do that when they sign the
application form uh and and the
affidavits that might be involved and
usually they do it on Election Day when
they
go to vote for the first time and they
register at the polling place but they
can also go into a clerk's office and do
it or they can go to a session of uh the
supervisors of the checklist I'm not
aware that that actually happens in any
other state in the country and that's
one of the strengths of our system
um uh because we have people that know
the community and and know the people in
it that are responsible for this and not
just some bureaucrat in a in a city that
is 100 miles away uh doing that same
job what is my biggest fear in in
maintaining the Integrity of the
election process
um any electronic system is vulnerable
uh to being hap
hacked and and we have to be vigilant
about that you know that danger can be
mitigated quite a bit and I can tell you
uh
New Hampshire is
probably uh one of the strongest States
currently in the steps that we are
taking to protect our uh elections
systems and we're doing that by having
third-party vendors uh uh that are
experts in this field some of them are
are former military um uh technology uh
experts um and we're doing a number of
things one is when we are having
software developed as we are for the
voter registration database as we would
for this voter portal um as we did for
the campaign Finance
system we are having the code uh heavily
scrutinized and reviewed uh even when
the vendors that are providing the
software are using uh third-party boiler
prate software like from Microsoft or
something like that we're having them
thoroughly go through it looking for
um uh issues that we you know that that
that might be there that nobody else is
aware of and I can tell you that in the
process of reviewing the um uh code that
is going into the voter registration
database uh there was
some code that was found uh in a I call
it a boilerplate
software that had
little code in there that uh uh when
executed would play the Ukrainian Anthem
and show a picture of the Ukrainian flag
you know obviously that was you know
that was removed from the software but
we're making sure that the software is
just clean right from the beginning and
then we are hire excuse me
hiring companies that can do penetration
testing from time to time uh that are re
reviewing the activity in and out who's
trying to access uh these databases and
things like that and I think at this
point New Hampshire really is on the
Forefront of what other states are doing
in that
regard the latest thing uh uh that is
surfacing this year now is artificial
intelligence um and that could be a real
potential problem in fact I appeared
before United States uh Senate uh
committee yesterday this group is far
more intimidating by the way
so um
but everybody
[Laughter]
smile um the ability now for anybody to
access a program through an app that can
take an image of anybody else and their
voice recording and create uh video an
audio of that person saying and doing
things that simply never happened is
incredible I mean it's
frightening and so you know the the uh
the trick there is being able to
identify you know what is a deep
fake and uh and making people aware of
it and if it's malicious Prosecuting
people that are you know that are
engaged in being you know really
deceptive uh in a disruptive way um so
you know I think that's that's the
biggest danger to our election process
is just staying on top of uh the
electronic systems that we do have and
making sure that they're safe thank you
all right I got two questions I want
just a quick followup um he's I
appreciate you bringing up the issue of
deep fakes but is it is it relates to
this particular system there's there's
nothing in our system this system that
relies on video or a virtual action it's
all the validation is all human to Human
um at at a designated location right
that's correct so the Deep fake um the
awareness is is not related to this uh
system that's right all right thank you
excellent answer we using up the
allotted time still got two more people
like to speak please limit the questions
and the answers representative tersi
thank you Mr chairman thank you
secretary scanland for taking my
question um it's my understanding that
the DMV and the voter fileer are already
talking to each other and I know when I
get a license I have to um bring forth
proof of identity proof of age proof of
residency which is three of the four
items needed for voter registration it
would seem to me that a portal could be
very efficient in terms of instant
verification um with those items that
have already been verified by the DMV is
that something that could be worked out
so that um that process could be um
integrated in a safe and protected
manner for voter registration I
certainly think think that's possible
down the road and you know I I I
mentioned about the Motor Voter law and
the national voter registration act in
the other states the the other states
have that because of the federal
requirement New Hampshire I didn't
mention this is exempt from that
law because at the time it was created
we had same day voter
registration
um I think that the information that
could be provided uh
electronically uh through a voter
portable portal could be
verified uh certainly provided the voter
was already in the system uh they may
have been registered in another town
Senator Grace said you know that data
already exists in the database it can be
prepared uh at this point the portal is
not being built to match information
with motor vehicles but uh if at some
point in the future you know that was
felt to be a good policy decision and we
could uh we could do that very quick
followup followup I guess I'm just
trying to understand because the way um
you were describing what you envision um
you're talking about the voter putting
their information in but then it sounded
like it's almost like they're printing
out a form with it pre-filled that you
then hand to a clerk that they have to
type it in that seems
like you're not taking advantage of the
electronic information as it comes in it
seems like we're just so close but not
quite getting there can you just expand
on what you're seeing this is what the
way I envisioned it is that the voter
would provide the data
electronically the clerk or the
supervisors of the checklist would print
out the
form that would have to be signed by the
voter there would be no other reentering
data it's just that there would be a wet
signature of the voter that applied for
that voter registration when they show
up to either vote for the first time at
the polling place or go to the clerk's
office uh to show their documentation to
back up their
application thank you if there's no
further questions please keep it
short thank you Mr chair I will be as
short as I can humanly be um two very
quick questions one in terms of the open
source versus the Dominion
machines you talked about reviewing the
code earlier do you have the same degree
of confidence in your the ability of
your tech people to review the code for
those two different
systems the the voting Works code
because it's open source uh is
reviewable by by anybody the Dominion
however is uh is proprietary they use
proprietary
software the towns would be acquiring
their
product if the town decides that they
want to use a machine
the the review that takes place is not
the vendors that I mentioned that that
review the New Hampshire specific code
when we're building it uh the review is
done by a thirdparty nationally
recognized uh Tech technological
laboratory uh looking for the
requirements that have been put in place
by the federal election assistance
Commission
and those standards are uniform uh you
know for those types of devices and uh
we have to trust them that you know that
they've done their job making sure that
the code of those various vendors is
clean thank you Mr secretary in the
interest of time I'll skip the second
question thank
you thank you thank you thank you Mr
secretary next person we call on is Liz
tentarelli League of Women Voters
welcome to
finance thank you representative Wier uh
thank you for the committee my name is
Liz tentarelli I'm president of the
League of Women Voters of New Hampshire
we're a nonpartisan organization and our
mission is to empower voters and I can
think of no better way to empower voters
than to make the regist rtion process
something that voters in the 21st
century can actually
recognize so instead of the trip to the
town clerk's office uh you can start
that process online if this bill passes
and the portal bill
passes um this is a funding
mechanism it seems like a very logical
use of State funds to encourage the Next
Generation of Voters beyond that it
Services the present generation of
Voters that is anybody Among Us who
moves from one town to another could
change address online rather than to
traes to another uh building in another
town with documents and so on so I very
much encourage this committee to support
this bill I hope you notice the list of
sponsors on the Senate bill it is a
bipartisan list voting should not be a
partisan issue we should all agree that
eligible voters should be able to
register to vote in the most logical and
convenient way possible and I think this
bill facilitates that so I urge my your
support of this bill on behalf of my
organization thank you thank you for
your testimony questions from the
committee seeing none well next call on
autumn roschi Goodwin open democracy
action welcome to finance thank
you all right I'm gonna keep this short
because I know we're
over uh for the record my name is Autumn
rashik Goodwin I am a Manchester voter
and the program coordinator for open
democracy action uh we are a nonprofit
nonpartisan organization that focuses on
advocating for campaign Finance reform
and for voter rights really I just want
to emphasize the importance of this bill
for the convenience for people
registering to vote a lot of people
aren't available during the typical
hours of the town clerk's offices so
being able to do all of this populating
of the forms ahead of time is just
extremely convenient makes it so that
they just have to pop in with documents
sign off good to go
additionally it will increase the
accuracy which we've already talked
about extensively today and it will save
funds for the different towns because we
don't have to spend as much time going
back and forth trying to decipher what
someone wrote on a paper
form um I do also have the testimony of
one of our volunteers Bob Perry with me
which I'll hand out with mine as well
thank you questions from the
committee okay this will be taken up
further in division one and uh you'll
look on the schedule for that couple of
weeks May
7th they have the uh sign up
sheet Jody Newell from Kean is pro
represent Heath Howard from straford is
also in
favor without
further yes representa hle thank you Mr
chair um unfortunately just left I was
going to ask a question of the Secretary
of State relative to if they have newer
data regarding participation in the
elections I can find up through 2020 um
it would be great if the office would
send us over
participation right we are near the top
in 2020 I would love to see what
happened in 2022 why don't you send him
a note so when he comes on May 7th he'll
have that data
available thank you all right I will
close the hearing now on
453 and open the hearing on senator Bill
499 and call on its prime sponsor
Senator
Whitley Mr chair I believe the public um
notice is not for $499 but it's actually
6:04 at
130 you're right I had them out of order
here thank
you
604 all right I have Senate Bill
604 and I have Senator rosenwall that's
here good
afternoon thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record I'm
Senator Cindy Rosenwald I represent
District 13 which is nashwa and I'm here
on behalf of Senator
delandro to introduce Senate Bill
604 this bill provides a death benefit
to the family of a security officer who
was killed in the line of duty last
November at New New Hampshire
hospital several years ago the state
enacted a law to provide a
$100,000 death benefit to the surviving
family members of law enforcement
officers and firefighters killed in the
line of Duty the individual who was gone
down in this terrible case was providing
security for New Hampshire hospital and
had been a sworn law enforcement officer
for his entire adult life including
serving as a police chief but he was not
a sworn law enforcement officer at the
time of his um
line of duty death so his family was not
eligible for the death
benefit to be
clear his family did not request this
legislation the Senate felt it was
simply the right thing to
do um for someone who dedicated his life
to law enforcement and protecting and
serving his community and who continued
to Serve and Protect after retirement in
his security role at New Hampshire
hospital he literally gave his life to
protect the staff and the patients of
the state hospital and the Senate felt
that ex extending this benefit to his
family was the proper thing to do and we
hope the house will agree thank you
thank you any questions for the senator
representa Sweeney thank you Mr chairman
thank you senator for being here and
introducing this bill was there any
conversation in the senate about
extending this benefit to any in the
unfortunate case the situation happens
again uh to other security officers in
the future or is it just retroactive to
officer H's
family there was a lot of discussion
about that I was not privy to any of it
but I know there was a lot this
particular bill
has the support of all of the
stakeholder
organizations it was a simple thing to
do what you're suggesting would be
probably um something that would need
work and
conversation this was a late filed
Bill thank you I appreciate that thank
you
yes
yes questions from the committee members
Edward thank you Mr chair and to follow
up on that very thing I I was thinking
pretty much the same thing if there if
there is any language that was floated
around on an amendment to this so that
we're making a categorical distinction
in the law as opposed to a oneoff
individual I I would be much more
comfortable about that being just good
legislative work to to not be
pinpointing individual benefits but to
to determine as policy what categories
we want to have covered by this benefit
do do are you aware of any language
thank you I'm not aware that there was
language floated this bill was not
amended in the Senate I just know there
were discussions about whether it should
be really narrow or whether it should be
more extensive and I think the decision
was that would be a longer
conversation perhaps for the next
legislative session as I said to rep
weeny this was a late filed Bill
and uh there was simply not a huge
amount of time to get it to get that
extension right and have the support
of the state troopers the police the
firefighters um this bill does have
broad support thank you Senator
appreciate the answer thank you Mr
chair any other questions from committee
members see none thank you
Senator Senator 6 Senate Bill
604 also have representative Hall
thank you members of finance
representative hle serving the towns of
dun Martin hooks at Allenstown and fum
here um in favor of this even as a
fiscal conservative um part of what went
on I think we also need to understand um
from the news reports CU I have not seen
firsthand information relative to
official sources but from what I've read
in the news the person serving the job
of security that night officer hos um
was in fact at the metal detector being
the security agent it it's my
understanding also that he was unarmed
at the time and that that was done by
Department policy or rule or contract or
something I believe
um the questions to the earlier speaker
about a broad benefit are definitely
worth discussing but if
we via our
policies disarm the security guard I
believe we owe that family this I think
there is right we own we own some
responsibility in that action I
testified to that on the floor when we
were talking about House Bill 1711 which
was also tied to officer
hos I think there is some level of
culpability for us as a state if we are
asking people to be security guards at
metal detectors at institutions where
there might be
problems and then we tell them they
can't have their own personal carry
device um he may or may not have been
wearing um a bulletproof vest we don't
have those details I think it's
worthwhile for us to figure out what
happened there as part of this in
addition to Simply making sure that the
family um is compensated for the loss of
someone they care for and quite frankly
$100,000 for someone who is murdered on
the job seems inadequate in my opinion
with that I'll close my
testimony thank you any questions from
the committee
members seeing
none
the signup sheet has
Cynthia babonis from conquer in favor
Elizabeth sergeant from New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police in favor
and
Barbara Barbara haros from FSB in
favor there's no further action on that
bill representative
lean thank you Mr chairman um I don't
see any need of this going on to the
division on May 7th so I'd like the move
passage is there a
second
oh there any objection to to executing
this bill
today represented my my objection would
would just be around process I I I'm I'm
uncomfortable obviously the state owes
it to the family to help in this
instance I have no issue with that my
issue is establishing a precedent where
we're in law identifying a an individual
for a particular benefit and I if we did
a work session on this I I would love to
work with somebody on an amendment that
would make this a categorical benefit
and make it retroactive so that this
individual family can benefit from it
but we're not kind of you know choosing
winners and losers on a legislative
basis so so that would be my objection
represent whole did you have an
amendment you wanted to present I do not
and for that reason I think it makes
sense to not EXA this today day but have
enough time to have an amendment drafted
I will get that done prior to an exec
session all right seeing the objection
we'll we'll wait to have further so that
this can be thoroughly worked on and
obviously there's members that want to
uh bring in amendments and ensure that
this carries forward so that this
example can be repeated if needed so I
just say
so so thank you Mr chair I just as a
point of personal privilege on this I I
just anyone who has heard my words I
want you to know I I care deeply about
making the family whole and and having
the legislature step into this I just
want to do it in a way in which it's
predictable for any future scenarios and
and I I I I think we're going to get
there I just don't I I just don't want
to get there directly so so thank you Mr
chair okay any further discussion on
that on that bill
604 all right seeing none the next bill
on the schedule at 2 o'clock is Senate
Bill
553 we've only allotted a half an hour
for that and I can see we're going to
exceed that but I'd like to say to those
of you that have signed up for
it since there is a large number of
people that all want to say something
about this if you have nothing new to
add and a other person has said the same
comments that you would like to
reproduce if you could just get up and
say I I am in favor and I support the
the uh comments that have been further
made that will help us get through that
in a more timely way if there's
something really new then say I not only
agree with the further with the former
comments but I'd like to add this so
that's what we're going to have to do
when we start at at 2:00 and uh I'll
probably have these sponsors Senator
rosenal is here have her introduce the
bill I think she's still yeah there she
so we'll take a uh a brief intermission
here because we cannot start before the
schedule time so we start at 2
o'clock
and collect any more cards for people
that want to testify on 5
appreciate it thank
you
e
e e
the finance committee to order for the
hearing of Senate Bill 553 and call upon
the sponsor Senator rosenwall welcome to
finance committee thank you I'm pleased
to be back here for the record I'm
Senator Cindy rosenal from District 13
in nashwa and I'm pleased to be here to
introduce Senate Bill
553 following its 24 to zero ought to
pass vote out of the Senate this bill is
both an economic stimulus Bill and a
property tax relief bill that is because
it will lead to job growth economic
expansion more small small business
lending and increased local and state
revenues
significantly so the public deposit
investment pool affectionately known as
P dip was created by Statute
in
1993 as a way for cities and towns to
collectively invest their cash
reserves and this pool was pretty small
until a couple of years ago it was worth
around $200
million but it now totals over
$650
million These funds which are mostly tax
pay funds none of them are currently
invested in New Hampshire and some of
them are held
overseas by Statute the state treasurer
is
responsible and has to hire a managing
Organization for this for the
p and the state treasurer also sets the
investment standards for PF so how much
in treasury notes how much in
CDs that that sort of thing and that has
um been the case since Creation with the
exception of a couple of years ago we
moved oversight of the fund itself from
the banking commission to the treasurer
this bill does not change these
responsibilities of the
treasurer she will still have to hire a
management company she will still set
the investment standards for the pool no
city or town is required to join the
pool and some of them don't what this
bill does require is that these funds
funds be invested in financial
institutions with a presence in New
Hampshire and it also requires that all
funds be secured or
collateralized this is I think important
because the top priority of the pp is
the safety of these
funds however up until now there has
never been insurance
or
collateralization of the
Investments and in fact last fall S&P
Global issued an analysis of of New
Hampshire's PP and mentioned that with
the daily liquidity set by the manager
at 10% of the total if there were a
large Redemption by a single investing
city or town or the
state um redemptions by other cities and
towns might be paused for up to five
days and could be redeemed in kind
instead of in
cash I think you'll probably hear that
this bill will kill the
pp I don't believe this is true and I
think it's based on a misunderstanding
of how it would work the treasurer as I
said will still have to hire a
management company just like she has to
do now and that company will negotiate
relationships and rates with some number
of banks that have a presence in New
Hampshire I think it clearly would not
be every bank but it would be some in
order to get the high yield that is
possible with a significant
investment and this would be and um a
strong
relationship it won't be every city in
town is what I'm trying to say going out
on their own and talking to their local
bank the management company will do this
and at least two local I'm sorry not
local at least two management companies
have already indicated interest in
seeking this business now I said at the
outset that Senate Bill 553 is both an
economic stimulus and a property tax
relief bill I say that because we know
from a study conducted last Fall by New
Hampshire Economist Brian gotab was here
here today what the impact of bringing
this over $600 million back to New
Hampshire and investing it with our
financial institutions would be Mr golob
was able to evaluate the effect just on
the commercial banking side which is
only
onethird of the total banking sector so
therefore his projections and models are
very
conservative but what they tell us is
that more than $200
million would be available for business
lending that would be particularly
helpful for small
businesses his study tells us that over
2500 jobs would be created and household
income would grow along with the state's
Dem domestic
product in addition we know and I think
you'll hear it that negotiated
relationships with banks are providing
nearly the same rate as the pp currently
generates and in fact we see this in
Maine which doesn't even have a PP and
negotiates almost the same rate so all
of this economic activity would
translate to Municipal Revenue growth of
67 million do over five years or at
least double the return our cities and
towns are getting now on the yield rate
from the current investment strategy
State revenues would grow by almost the
same amount when all of the revenues
from our various tax sources are
considered and when the consumer Landing
side 2third of the banking sector is
added the revenue impact would be even
greater and these Revenue impacts would
continue to
multiply over time as businesses and
jobs grow and household wealth
accumulates I um I'm not an economist
I'm not a scientist I'm not an engineer
but I like to think in
metaphor and some of you know I'm
married to a
Cardiologist so I imagine the P dip as a
circulatory
system if we look only at the yield
which is what we currently do we are
only seeing the aorta of the heart
receiving blood
that's just pumped out of the heart but
if we invest this money in New Hampshire
we will see the entire circulatory
system with oxygen rich blood flowing
throughout the body of New Hampshire's
economy down even to its fingers and
toes and that's what this bill I believe
will do it will put our money to work in
our communities and P pump more money
throughout New Hampshire while also
serving as a way to provide tap property
tax relief and do so in a way that is
safe and liquid I'm happy to answer
questions thank you Mr chairman
representative Petri for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank and welcome
back to uh fin thank you I'm happy to be
here right who is the current manager of
the
pool now it's a company called pfm and I
believe they're here today thank
you okay further questions from the
committee representative Heath thank you
Mr chair thank you senator for taking my
question um just um I didn't see it
anywhere in the bill when if the state
takes over kind of coordination of all
of this out of the treasurer's office
will at any point in time the state have
access to any of the interest dollars at
all so the state already is responsible
for managing this the state is allowed
by Statute to put some money into the BP
I believe we have
some um and so that will
generate interest or yield right
now um what I think you'll hear from Mr
G
is what the state revenue impacts would
be from the various business taxes
property taxes rooms and Mills because
of the economic expansion all right
thank you all right let's keep things
short representative papichi M thank you
Mr chairman thank you senator for taking
my question um it seems that the purpose
of the legislation is to obviously
require that all the Investments be made
in New
Hampshire has there been an analysis
done over the fact that this will likely
result in lesser yields and it will make
the PDP less attractive to the towns and
cities that are using it so you will
hear
from um other people what kind of rates
will be
generated based on the relationship
ships they they currently have and
probably based on what states like Maine
have but in addition we will get um the
cities and towns will get the
added money from property
taxes the additional rooms and meals tax
distributions remember they get
30% so as that
Pi
expands got it thank you it will be
calculated Mr gam I think will tell you
that the cities and towns will generate
an extra $67 million over five years
looking only at onethird of the banking
sector all right no further questions
from committee thank you
Senator next call on
Brian golob has been
mentioned oh sorry I am for the record
I'm Brian golop principal of polycon
research and economic research firm
located in Dober New Hampshire some of
you may also know me um in my other role
which is the director of the state's
economic and labor market information
Bureau
here to say that I am um taking leave
time to come and testify in support of
this particular bill um I believe and
Senator Rosenwald referenc the study I
conducted I'm not going to take you
through it is very long exhaustive I
believe you'll all have copies of it um
I will talk a little bit about some of
the data in there and some of the
updates because when I did that analysis
it was based on data U from June of 20
uh 23 when there was 500 $30 million in
the pool and now there is as mentioned
over $600 million um I think the report
makes a compelling economic case for
investing those funds in New Hampshire
um I think you will see that when you
look at the report but I'm also here to
talk about what I think is the ethical
reasons for doing that um the dollars
that we obtain cities towns and state
from taxpayers households and businesses
I think ought to be deployed uh to
benefit those households individuals and
businesses and the state's economy um
currently um I was surprised when I
first started doing my research to learn
that over $600 million is not going to
benefit um households businesses and the
state economy and in fact is going um
largely to
organizations um throughout the country
and in importantly throughout the world
um people that I talked to households
businesses were largely unaware of this
um I think they shared in large numbers
the uh view that I shared that that
money that we give to the state we give
to the towns ought to be used to benefit
towns and the state of New Hampshire and
its economy I do believe in free markets
I'm a business person I believe in free
markets Senate Bill 550 three does not
mandate that any Community where it
should invest its
funds but if they choose to invest those
funds in the
pitp I believe that's an organization
that was established by this legislature
and sanctioned by this
legislature and as a result of that I
think it ought to support the goals and
objectives and policies of this body and
I believe the primary polic policy
objective of the New Hampshire
legislature is to increase the
well-being the prosperity of
individuals businesses and the state
economy
overall currently $600 million of
taxpayer funds does not go to meet that
objective keeping public funds in New
Hampshire will increase access to
business credit that is really the focus
of the research Senator rosenal
mentioned I did not Factor in the
increase in credit availability that
would occur as a result of lending to
households I did that for a particular
reason small businesses really rely on
credit from local banking institutions
for their lifeblood they do not for the
most part have access to credit
Nationwide households to a large extent
do there's fintech there's opportunities
to to borrow from organizations
throughout throughout the country over
90% of the deposits in in New Hampshire
banks are lent out 34% based on the last
10 years Senator rosewald mentioned is
for businesses largely for small
businesses in the
state there are organizations throughout
this state that seek and understand the
importance of business credit and look
to expand access to credit for small
business we have the small business
administration we have the New Hampshire
business Finance Authority and we have
Regional economic development
organizations throughout the state with
lending pools all with one objective and
that's to increase credit to small
businesses SB 553 is a way to do that
does not establish a new organization
and it does not require any public funds
it's the easiest and simplest way you
can increase credit to businesses and
expand the the New Hampshire economy
so what are the impacts based on the
updated information that I have first
that two 200 over $200 million of
additional business credit largely small
businesses will increase the state's
gross domestic product there's a strong
relationship between growth in state
Gross State product and growth in state
and local revenues very strong
statistical
relationship so 200 over $200 million
increase in Gross State product over
2,000 more jobs
combined state and local Revenue
increases just in year 2024 I estimated
about $26 million but over and over a
fiveyear period $129 million split
fairly evenly between state and local
and and is outlined in the report where
I detail the individual tax revenues
state tax revenues that I that I believe
will be increased but $129 million over
5 years there will also be additional
because there'll be additional economic
opportunities be increase of I estimate
2100 individuals population in New
Hampshire and 1,300 over 1300
individuals in our labor force and
that's all while providing interest
income at about the same rate as is
currently
being achieved through investment in the
New Hampshire Public deposit investment
pool there was a question asked earlier
what is the current rate well there is
no one current rate because communities
negotiate individually with banks I
spoke to a number of Banks and asked
them what their rate was I spoke to a
number of of
organizations that had the choice of
going into the public deposit investment
pool and the reality is the rates are
very very close but what tips the
balance is when you add the revenue and
the economic gains from investing in New
Hampshire it's not even close the
combined yield is approximately double
what is achieved through investment in
the public deposit investment pool for
all of these reasons um I ask your
support for Senate Bill 553 and with
that I'll take questions could you
ensure that we all get a copy of your
report I don't think I've seen it yet
sure I think it
is if you've given it to well we will
get report a copy of the report I was I
didn't realize you so the key to my mind
is what is the total lending from all
the banks in the state at this
time um I somewhere in the order
of it's 15 16 billion more I it's really
hard for me to to to say um I I I know
what the deposits are I don't really
maybe maybe we'll hear that from some
okay some other person because to me
it's critical whether you're talking
about the 685 million getting added to a
billion or add to 10 billion either is a
little piece or it overcomes it briefly
so those are those are key figures in My
Mind questions from committee Members
First representative McGuire then
representative
string thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for coming and I I really like the
elme uh Community profile section I've
used those for years they're great
um so aren't there some downsides here
in this in both in risk and and in
reward in the sense that um this would
concentrate um all these Savings in the
state and should the state God forbid
have some kind of a regional or local
disaster wouldn't that put these funds
at risk in a way that if they were
elsewhere would not and and secondly at
a time when it you know they might be
very needed and then in reward um if we
guarantee that these funds can only be
invested in the state wouldn't that make
the um the banks and so on in the
State uh because they have this
guaranteed sort of investment they
wouldn't have to be quite as competitive
as they do now yeah one thing I would
say is that they're not guaranteed
anything because because communities are
not required to invest if there became
if Senate Bill 553 passed there's
nothing arguing that a community has to
continue or would have to invest in in
in New Hampshire it could invest choose
another investment advisor and go
wherever it chose to go so there's no
guarantee of any money I also do think
that there is a real competition among
banks for those funds you
know local banks
acquiring deposits is key it's key to
their growth it's key to their ability
to lend and so there will be pretty
significant competition for those funds
because it's a way of
adding adding deposits and increasing
the potential for profitability so I
think there'll be plenty of competition
as far as the risk goes there's risks
there is no collateralization required
of the P pitp funds which means there is
no guarantee deposits in New Hampshire
Banks are required to have collateral so
there is a guarantee offered there so I
would argue it reduces
risk thank you so one one followup so is
there any particular reason why we
couldn't do both right why why can't we
have two funds one is is can be invested
anywhere one that's invested only in New
Hampshire and allow the municipalities
to decide do they want to put all their
money in one all in the other some
combination Etc what's wrong with that
representative Maguire that's well
beyond my payg grade to me that's a
that's a policy decision and and not was
outside the realm of my research so I
really can't speak to that
representative Stringham for a question
uh thank you for your testimony and
thanks for taking my question the
question I have is uh um you kind of
following the uh econometric logic is if
uh um say you're required to invest in
New Hampshire uh you put the Money in
the Bank of New Hampshire
or Citizens Bank uh that are doing lots
of local lending now uh wouldn't they
just decrease the amount of money
they're getting from from outside of of
New Hampshire s most most banks operate
in more than one state um I assume we're
not going to be investing in a Jenkins
Bike Shop directly uh our investments
will go through local financial
institutions who will then just change
the mix of where their funds come from
and where they go I think the the the
protection there uh and I've heard this
before well if the money goes to New
Hampshire Bay there's no guarantee that
they lend in New Hampshire well there is
a guarantee there's a requirement called
this community reinvestment act that
looks at Banks
and looks at their um their their
practices and meeting the credit needs
of households and individuals in their
operating regions and they're graded on
that so there is an expectation that
money that is obtained locally and
deposited in local banks will be
invested in the local Regional economy
either through household or business
Ling or in other way so there is some
there is some guarantee there quick
followup follow but don't they also get
money from out of
state it you know I think that would
really depend on on uh particular Banks
I my and I I'm not a banker and I
apologize to all the bank Bankers in
this room I'm assuming that most local
banks Community Banks primarily receive
their deposits from local organizations
and individuals but I could be wrong and
they'd have to address that why don't we
wait until we have Bankers there's going
to be several of them if you have
banking
questions let's hear from the people who
are the
bankers represent Edwards uh uh thank
you Mr chair um so I'm I'm I'm not
particularly familiar with RSA 645 so I
just Googled it it's the one that sets
up the public depos deposit investment
pool and what I was looking for as I was
looking in there was to determine
whether or not uh the law established a
clear fiduciary responsibility within
this fund to uh optimize a risk reward
balance uh which is typical of most
investment funds they have a fiduciary
responsibility of maximizing a return on
investment within safety
criteria is is that sort of language
already in 645 and I'm just missing it
again um not I'm not a lawyer I'm an
economist so I I can't uh really so my
followup though is would wouldn't that
actually maybe be a better way to go is
to make sure that this fund is set up
with the right fiduciary
responsibilities and the proper
investment objective uh and to delegate
to them the option of where they invest
as long as they're making a proper risk
reward benefit analysis I there's a
number of ways to measure reward um I'm
an economist I look at economic uh
rewards and that means what's happening
to the state's GDP what's happening to
personal income which by the way I
estimate would increase by about $ 1.7
billion dollar out till
2030 um if those funds were invested in
New Hampshire uh but it you know risk
reward if you're looking at a simple
return in terms of interest income or a
yield on an investment is one way of
maximizing returns I take a broader View
and I think based on the you my belief
that funds in New Hampshire ought to
benefit New Hampshire there's many ways
that that can occur and one way is to
create more job opportunities and more
um thank you Mr sure so I I do think
that all right we don't have I can't
really speak to that I'm sorry
representative papichi M just a very
quick question uh besides I I assume
that you'd be uh here to testify during
the work session on this bill would that
be something I should assume um I will
make myself available I would appreciate
that and my question is when
you created your model right did you
assume that for example the
interest Return of the investments will
be the same regardless of the change in
the legislation did you assume that
every dollar now that's now invested out
of state will now be invested in state
could you talk about those assumptions
yeah and those are all in the report um
my analys yeah the my analysis used a
range of uh possible returns from local
banks um ranging from a low of 3% up to
5.5%
currently the pitp is something over 5%
so I I didn't go above really go above
that but looked at what the combined
return would be in terms of tax revenue
for the state state and local
communities plus the interest income
earned on that money at 3% three and a
half% all the way through and made those
assumptions also made the same
assumptions on the economic returns
depending on what the yield or what the
interest income would be so there's a
full range uh of of those kinds of
analysis thank you members if you could
hold your questions you'll be hearing
from Bankers you'll be hearing from the
people who invest the money you'll be
hearing from many people who oppose the
bill and we want to be hearing from them
as well so thank you Mr godb thank you
for your testimony I'll next call on
looks like both names are on the card
Christy Merill and Chris Logan from the
New Hampshire Bankers Association
welcome to
finance good
afternoon thank you chairman Wier and
honorable members of the house finance
committee my name is Christy Merill I
have the honor of serving as president
and CEO of the New Hampshire Bankers
Association and with me today I have
Chris Logan and Chris serves as
president and CEO of Bank of New
Hampshire um New Hampshire Bankers
represents 42 member banks who employ
roughly 6,000 people in New Hampshire
and we are here today in support of
Senate Bill
553 um we are in supported this
legislation for two main
reasons as you heard earlier this
legislation grows New Hampshire's
economy and second it levels the playing
field for public funds since the state
created The Entity known as PB it
competes against a private banking
industry and is not currently required
to secure or collateralize funds um we
in I have my testimony for each of you
um we have a one-pager of Brian's study
but we can get you the full study and
you've heard the results um in his
update so I won't get into that but I do
want to just expound a little bit on the
point that he made about the results
being conservative um Senator Rosenwald
mentioned that um so what we know is
according to the FDIC in New Hampshire
um the loan to deposit ratio is
90% And so what that means is for every
dollar a bank takes in deposits 90 cents
um is Lent back out into the community
sorry apparently it's my alarm to not
fall asleep um so uh sorry about that
um so when Brian conducted his study
what he did look at he mentioned that he
focused on the commercial lending
landscape and he said commercial lending
makes up 34% of that entire lending
picture so what what is lending include
in New Hampshire that includes mortgages
that conses uh includes Consumer loans
auto loans those types of things that
was not included in his analysis so
although um the numbers are pretty
impressive they are still conservative
it's about a third of the lending
picture so I just want to just highlight
that point um so what does the economic
study mean in Practical terms um you can
you'll probably hear more about this
later on but Banks because the loan to
deposit ratio is 90% a lot of banks are
lent out and they would like to lend
more into the communities and they can't
do that unless they have additional
deposits and so this legislation would
allow 600 million in PP to be put to
work through additional forms of
lending we've heard a little bit about
how access to credit by small businesses
is an issue and this will address that
Brian mentions it's an additional 209
million increased credit and that would
um be available to small businesses and
families allowing them to expand their
operations and hire more people and this
could also mean additional financing for
developers um including for affordable
housing project projects conversely
funds invested in PIP are not kept
locally at the Senate Finance hearing on
Senate Bill 553 um the fund managers
testified that zero New Hampshire
taxpayer dollars remain in New Hampshire
you can look at the list of where the
funds are invested but three that I'll
just highlight for you uh National
Australia Bank scandinava incal bankin
in Sweden uh Sumit Tomo sui Bank in
Japan sorry I can't pronounce those very
well um so the other reason that we
support this legislation is because it
levels the playing field and so what do
we mean by that taxpayer funds in PIP
are not required to be secured or
collateralized Banks however are
required to offer
collateralization through FDIC Insurance
taxpayer funds are backed by the full
faith and credit of the US government up
to
$250,000 and Banks can um ensure funds
beyond that through various products in
addition to Insurance Banks can offer
collateralization through a letter of
credit from the federal Home Loan Bank a
repurchase agreement with the Federal
Reserve or pledging of other high
quality Securities and assets while it
is prudent to secure taxpayer funds
there is a cost to that and this is not
a cost that pip is required to
Bear uh the requirement to collateralize
is is common around the country and just
a few states that do that as an example
Louisiana New Jersey Mississippi Oregon
Texas and New York cities and towns have
the ability to invest outside the pool
however the investment of funds is
required to be in obligations fully
backed by the US government and
repurchase agreements fully
collateralized by S such options um the
RSA for that is RSA 4816 and so while
Finance officers have multiple options
they can they can Finance directly with
banks that has to be collateralized they
can Finance through directly with other
investment options that has to be
collateralized but when they put funds
in PP it does not so why do we need to
change now a lot has happened since the
creation of pup over 30 years ago
especially when it comes to how funds
are managed I'm guessing 30 years ago
you probably rote a lot more checks you
probably kept up your check register and
you probably saved all of your receipts
most people don't do that as much
anymore personal finances changed a lot
and so has Municipal Finance um today
the tools to secure and collateralize
funds are available simply did not exist
and were not as available 30 years
ago um so one of the things that we have
heard in this discussion um and you may
hear later today is that there is no
requirement for banks to keep funds
local and how do we know that fund that
banks are actually keeping uh funds
local uh you you folks are very close to
your communities and you're out and
about and I would just encourage you
when you see a project when you see a
development take a look at the financing
and the odds are one of the banks that
has a presence here in New Hampshire did
that project but as was mentioned banks
are subject to the community
reinvestment act and they are regularly
examined every few years on their
compliance and what does that mean that
means the bank is expected to meet the
needs of the communities which it serves
through Investments services and lending
so and this is required in each market
so if there's out of State Banks um but
they they are in New Hampshire they have
a presence in New Hampshire they're
expected to comply in New Hampshire each
Bank receives a rating which is public
it's either outstanding satisfactory
needs to improve or substantial
non-compliance and I want to emphasize
this point each bank that has a rating
lower than satisfactory they must cure
that rating in a certain period of time
if they failed to do so there will be
corrective action there is no tolerance
for failing to comply with the CRA
all banks all of our member banks
located here have either outstanding or
satisfactory ratings and it shows that
they meet the spirit of the CRA and they
support the communities they serve um
and here's just really quickly this is
how the FDIC explains the CRA the law is
intended to encourage depository
institutions to help meet the credit
needs of the communities in which they
operate including low and moderate
income neighborhoods consistent with
safe and sound banking
operations additionally New Hampshire
laws require that out of-state banks
that do business with public funds they
have to have a presence here they have
to pay taxes here and they have to lend
into the community approximately as much
as they take in
deposits finally um many of you are
familiar with the small business
administration and they put out regular
reports on their loan activity for their
products um and we've included a few of
those reports and you will you can look
at those I encourage you to do so and
you'll see that the Lion Share of those
loans are done by banks with presence
here um so I think we're going to hear a
little bit more about rates today so
just really quickly I want to mention um
we've got a handout that shows the bank
versus PP rate if you look back five
years the 30-day treasury is very close
in some cases higher um I would love to
be able to list every bank and what
their rates are but we're not allowed to
do that um we can get in trouble for
doing so so we use the 30-day treasury
as a guide and the 30-day treasury um is
something Banks use to be an indicator
for how to set their rates um um during
the Senate hearing the treasurer also
testified that she's getting as much as
5.25% at of Bank in 2020 when the pp
rate was close to 0% the asset manager
started waving its fees to show positive
returns and that's also included a copy
of that is in your packet we've heard
about how the pool creates competition
and that's why banks are able to offer
the rates that they do um as was pointed
out though in Maine and Vermont neither
state has a pool and they have
competitive rates there
um I do want to talk a little bit about
safety um we've heard this elsewhere you
may hear it later today um you'll hear
that petp offers AAA rated Investments
and they've never lost money in 31 years
and we are not arguing that these are
not safe Investments um but what we are
arguing is pup funds are not insured
they are not secured and they are not
collateralized Banks however through
FDIC Insurance um taxpayer funds are
backed by the full faith and credit of
the US government up to 250 and Beyond
um and bank secure funds and Banks
collateralized funds while pip funds are
safe Investments there is still risk in
1994 Orange County California they filed
bankruptcy after its pool experien large
losses in 2007 a Florida pool which was
the largest pool in the country at that
time had about a th000 participants and
27 billion in assets they had to pause
redemptions due to a high volume of
requests exhausting the liquid assets
during the financial CR crisis their
pool was created into two funds fund a
allowed redemptions but put a limit on
the request and participants faced a 2%
penalty if the reduction I'm sorry if
the Redemption was above that limit fund
B did not allow withdrawals until the
assets matured and the money was
eventually paid back by
2014 uh more recently in 2015 a similar
government pool in Chicago experienced
losses um you were probably a going to
hear and we've heard elsewhere that
there are only three AAA rated banks in
New Hampshire um but we'd like to point
out that this is really an apples and
oranges comparison ratings are only
required for debt issuances that are
widely traded where the risk uh sorry
where the risk of loss is present
generally speaking Community Banks do
not issue these type of debt Securities
therefore most are not rated and as
we've said earlier Banks provide
insurance and collateralization which
protect taxpayer funds uh you may be
familiar with the state's annual
comprehensive financial report and in
that document it explains that all banks
where the state has active accounts are
monitored on the Financial Health using
the Vera Bank rating system um in which
verab bank is A Bank rating firm and the
institution is expected to have the
highest rating of green if you look at
the verbank ratings for banks in New
Hampshire you will find that 37 are
green um finally I'd like to just point
out um um that there are there are those
that say that this legislation will end
the pool um and this legislation is not
intended for that it's intended to level
the playing field um it was amended in
the Senate so it would not impact the
relationship the state has with the
current fund manager and as was
mentioned earlier there are two fund uh
management companies around the country
that have expressed interest in this
legislation that they are monitoring it
and we understand um at least for one of
those companies their model is to
partner with with banks and so they
would take public funds and place them
in local banks um and um and yes did you
have a question Mr chair is that my
signal to I'm hoping since at this
moment I will open the hearing on Senate
Bill
499 and recess it till
3:30 so those of you that have come in
here for Senate Bill 499 we won't get to
that till at least 330 i' also since you
hopefully have the big picture yes as
the banking Association I've never heard
the figure I'm always seeking yes to add
650 million to the loans that are
already being made yes what are what is
the size of the loan already being made
are you doubling the available funds are
you adding 10% are you tripling it this
these all have a big effect on what the
what would happen so what is the present
loan from all the banks now yes
absolutely do you want to do that or do
you so I don't have the exact number I
don't want to pretend I know this number
off top of my head but roughly there's
$50 billion worth of deposits in the
state of New Hampshire and if I would
say for certainly for main Charter Banks
we're loaned up at 90% National Banks
not as much so I'm gon to say it's a
range between 40 and 44 million billion
dollars in loans okay that that's
significant because I don't want this
600 million overcoming the market that
it will not happen so you know we're
maybe risks would be taken that wouldn't
be otherwise thank you very much for
that figure uh and do you have further
Mr Logan if uh for brevity for time I
would just like to answer a few
statements that have been said that um
will probably come out in this so one of
the comments um about this bill and the
concern is about the rate and we've
heard Brian and and uh talk about the
rate and I won't get into a lot of facts
but I did work at a Maine Community Bank
for 15 years before I was in New
Hampshire and I can assure you that the
competition in Maine for municipal
deposits is very strong and the rates
are very similar um secondly I think
when we look at what Brian's uh study
said I thought it was logical that if we
invested our dollars in New Hampshire it
was going to provide a greater return
for our communities we commissioned a
study so we could prove that fact for
someone just to say they think the facts
and figures around it are not logical
I'm not sure is a is a just
response thank um two two other op so
open market maret so there's there's
questions about whether or not this is
uh not allowing a free market or open
market Senate Bill 102 in 1992 built
this fund that is not an open market so
initially it was built by the government
so if the fund wasn't there it would be
an open market and lastly I would just
uh um talk about CRA lots of questions
about whether or not the dollars will be
spent here in New Hampshire I'm going to
extrapolate banking New Hampshire
numbers for CRA if I extrapolate what we
have for business loans donations and
volunteer hours over the last two years
we would do $1.1 billion in commercial
loans we'd have 13 million in donations
and at 33,000 volunteer hours so my
question to you would be what has pfm
done for our
communities thank you questions from the
committee representative papich Mueller
thank you Mr chair I'll be very
brief what um are you saying right now
that uh you have uh
high quality loans that you'd like to
make and you do not have the funds to
make I think today with where Community
Banks are with the leverage ratios loan
deposit ratios people have to decide how
to use their resources A bank's raw
materials are deposits we take our raw
materials to make loans right for
manufacturing company so when we have
fewer deposits it's harder to make loans
so it it forces you to make more choices
so at this point you are saying that you
would need more Capital to
make more loans of the same quality that
you are making today or not I'm just
trying to understand I I can only
comment on Bing New Hampshire yes on you
for Bank in New Hampshire yes I can make
more loans at the same quality and not
increase the risk profile of our
bank represent hacken
Phillips thank you Mr chair um thank you
both for taking my question um first I
just wanted to say as someone who sat
inside a financial institutions
boardroom during the 0809 financial
crisis in Chicago I can tell you the
importantance importance of the
community reinvestment Act and the real
positive impact it can make on a
community um so I appreciate all the
hard work that your lending institutions
and member
organizations um contribute to our state
um through that work um I was wondering
if you could just take a moment to
explain the IC in a little bit more
detail to help uh folks here on the
committee who may have some concerned
about um potential risk-taking above the
$250,000 FDIC insured threshold
limits so IC is a program that was
developed I'm guessing 20 years ago give
or take it wasn't around in
1990 and I I'll break it down to real
simple terms so FDIC insurance is
250,000 so if there was a million dollar
deposit
$750,000 or three chunks of 250 would be
shipped out to other banks that have
have FDIC insurance that they would then
send back
$750,000 to Bank of New Hampshire so
Bank of New Hampshire would still have
the millionar but it would have full
insurance because it would be split up
amongst four different banks I won't go
into a lot of detail but if that if that
suffices for
time further questions from Committee
Member representative Edwards thank you
Mr chair I'm I'm I'm looking at the bill
and the and the bill basically would
mandate that all funds held by the
public deposit investment pool be
invested or depos deposited within the
state of of New Hampshire and that all
funds held by a public deposit
investment pool are insured or
collateralized the second part of that
makes eminent sense to me insurance and
collateralization makes perfect sense um
would would would this bill still be
effective and useful in your opinion if
we struck the requirement that
everything be invested or deposited
within the state of New Hampshire that
that's what sounds anti-competitive to
me yeah um I I mean I would say that um
I I don't think we see it as as being
anti-competitive but understand that
your perspective representative um the
collateralization piece is really the
one that contributes to the unlevel
playing field um I think it would be
preferred to see some of the funds stay
within New Hampshire um but we
understand that um that legislation this
legislation is in your possession to do
with what you will so um the
collateralization is really import
important um and of course we'd like to
see some funds work in New Hampshire and
there are are other models I mentioned
one of the fund managers and uh that's
interested in this legislation and they
have a presence in other states where
there is a instate requirement not at
100% but there is an instate
requirement representative AEL for a
question then representative mire yes
very quick one um I don't know if you
can answer this question and thank you
for being here of the uh states in the
country that have dips is how many of
them would you say restrict the
Investments to instate Banks I really I
I don't know I couldn't answer that um I
know that there are states that have
some limitations um a handful I've
learned that there is uh New York and
Iowa um and my understanding is Indiana
they have some requirement to have um a
presence with that that the funds have
to stay in state um my understanding is
that there are also different types of
funds meaning there's a prime funds
where commercial paper is an acceptable
type of investment in other funds and
then there are what's known as govy
funds um which would be Securities
repurchase agreements and and Bank
products so there are probably others
that can speak better to
that represent Maguire for question
thank you Mr chairman you said that when
a a dollar is deposited 90 cents gets Lo
lent out but my understanding of
fractional Reserve banking is is
different that that when a dollar is
deposited the FED lets Banks loan out $2
or $150 or something else isn't that
right I I think what you're talking is
about the money multiplier that won't be
wouldn't be on the bank's balance sheet
but the money multiplier would be is
once this gets lend out and then that
company gets it they then reinvest it no
I'm
sorry I guess I I mean we certainly for
a bank the loan deposit ratios are not
multiples above 100%
thank you and may I follow yeah so I I
want to um um push back a little on your
answer to representative papovich Mller
and that is you're currently lending out
say 15 $50 billion some some amount
right and presumably those are to the
most creditworthy B borrowers and so if
you add extra money to be lent out
wouldn't those necessarily go to people
that did not qualify for the money
you're currently lending out namely the
worst borrowers so wouldn't the net
effect of this be to um increase the
fraction of your loans that are
non-performing I I would disagree with
that statement because of the fact that
there's there's been a limit on deposit
so banks have had to make choices over
certainly over the past several years as
liquidity has gotten tighter in the
market so there has been there has been
well qualified borrowers that have
struggled to get the capital they wanted
so I don't believe it's going to
Downstream to less worthy
borrowers further questions from
committee members seeing none thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
now we're going to hear from many of the
opposed people we first call on Chuck
Nickerson from New Hampshire Association
of
counties someone I am well familiar with
there you gok thank you good afternoon
thank you for having me uh my name is
Chuck Nickerson I'm the finance instor
for rockim County and I'm representing
the New Hampshire Association of
counties and I guess uh contrary to what
um testimony we've already had so far I
would actually disagree that this bill
as written to me will indeed mean the
end of the PDP the reason is that if I'm
investing funds and there's going to be
a fee for a fund manager why would I go
to the PDP if I'm gonna you know unless
I'm going to go to you know you know T
bills or whatever I'm just going to put
the money directly in the bank so to me
this would mean the end of the
pool I'm Rockham County we have only a
relatively small amount but I can say
that if this bill goes through then I'd
be recommending to my Board of
Commissioners into the treasurer for us
to pull our money out and go elsewhere
because I have a finary responsibility
to my County to my County's taxpayers
and just like all the other nine
counties do as well so again why would I
put money in the pool if it's going to
be mean less of a net return versus just
going to the bank
directly so that's a primary reason why
the association with couny is opposed to
this also again just from a general you
know Fu shary for the county you know
this does limit
diversification it does and as far as
the money's going outside the state I
mean I'm using any little B of excess
you know return that the count is
getting to actually not have to as much
raised in taxes so while it's not Direct
directly benefiting it cre be said
that's not directly benefiting the
taxpayers in a way it is because I'm
using any B ex return to not ask press
much in taxes from the Commissioners
from the
delegation so that's you know those are
key points and again just from the
standpoint of diversification that's
always a good rule if you can but this
again takes out fully one option that is
currently available to the counties to
municipalities I know for akam County
alone it'd be you know it is a less
lesser rate of return it is as far as if
it was fully in Banks versus the current
PF rate uh for our 2 million roughly
investment it'd mean like $40,000 annual
decrease from when I was able to compare
to the existing regular depository rates
that we have uh currently or at least
During the period of time that I
analyzed this for the last year and a
half so those are the primary reasons
why uh the Hampshire Association of
counties is against this uh bill and I
welcome any questions questions from
committee members
representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here it was
suggested an amendment to this bill that
the portion regarding being within New
Hampshire be removed but the rest of
that sentence remain would the New
Hampshire Association of counties
support that Amendment again it comes
down to if we're being restricted again
diversification wise if it's going to
have to go into Banks per se because I
believe it still basically says banks
that if it's going to mean less of a
return and I'm paying a fee basically to
a middle person I'm going to pull the
money out so not necessarily would that
make enough of a
difference thank you representative Papa
I'm a bit confused so I want to clarify
the previous question the question was
about whether the only only thing that
the bill does says that funds have to be
insured or collateralized nothing else
would you then still be opposed well the
way that almost implies investment in
banks that almost impli as far as being
fully collateralized that almost implies
invest insured or collateralized there
are ways to guarantee the you know
basically there would be a small cost
involved but you would have a lesser
risk of losing funds in the event of a
meltdown again is that just by just that
by itself something that you would
oppose or not it would be a again it' be
I don't think it's it's enough I mean
thank you and one thing I would like to
say as well if I could um is that as far
as you know there're being risk as far
as yes the pp Investments right now
obviously they're not collateralized
just by the nature of what the
Investments are however to my knowledge
there has not been an issue with any
town city county having issues
withdrawing their funds as they have
required or not required have requested
of the pool that's my understanding
since its
creation represent hole for a question
yes thank you Mr chair earlier um the
question was asked what if this policy
was one that allowed for two concurrent
funds that were administered right one
that was New Hampshire Centric within
and one that was our current traditional
fund Administration would you as the
Comm the committee sorry the county
representative have the same concerns if
there were people had the choice which
fund to put money into I mean if there
was a choice but again if if the
allegation is being made that well then
that still allows for not to be a fair
playing field then we might be back here
again with another bill to follow up
again request right but if you had a say
in how that money was right it it would
still allow for the current option yes
to invest you know whether it's it's in
state or out of state
you know whether or not you know not
fully
collateralized um so obviously if the an
ex the existing option is still
available then yes that would have an
effect okay I
feel thank you further questions from
committee members seeing none thank you
Mr Nickerson see you again
yes well next call on catch frock pfm
asset
management and also I see Mike mlin I
have cards from both of you from pfm
thank you for coming
together uh good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of Comm it's Mike mlof I'm a
lawyer in lobbies and cin with kacha
frock who is a director of pfm who was
the administrator of the fund uh quick
history on the fund the fund was created
years ago because cities towns uh
trustees and trust funds could not
invest in the instruments that being
invested Ed by the state or by the en
Hampshire retirement system so before
the PIP came into position the cities
and towns had nowhere to go with the
money but to Banks and at that time the
banks were faltering and the PIP was put
together to help get the cities and
towns some opportunities there were
240 uh individual investors in the PIP
and the thing that I think needs to be
remembered is well we're talking about
global terms where a Manchester asash
can walk into a bank with $20 million
and say what kind of a deal can I get
Wilton or wolfb or Warner comes in with
their 50 or
$100,000 and they don't have the same
power the public deposit investment pool
provides every single investor with the
same return the return is available
publicly uh and they're shareholders so
what we have here is really our own
mutual fund created by by this by the
legislature uh the shareholders own
those Securities the diversification is
where the protection comes in uh I'll
let ker talk a little bit about the
technicalities of the fund but we need
to remember it's the small towns and
cities the trustees of cemeteries the
libraries uh the Water commissions who
are putting money to work uh one who
need the PIP more than the large cities
uh there was some comments about the
money's not working New Hampshire if you
put $100,000 into the PIP and you pick
up 20,000 or five whatever you get in
the industry back to your city that
money goes right to your town it works
directly in the town if you take that
money away every dollar that's taken
away is a dollar would replaced by
property taxes or reduction Services
there's no other alternative for the
city of town or the trustees of the
library or the Water Commission they'll
have to reduce Services um there is a a
little bit of a uh a myth here about
Banks and my wife was a banker for 30
years small businesses if you give the
bank $600 million or even $60 million
there's a process they have to go
through to qualify that credit this
isn't mean they're going to make loans
to uh bad credit they're just not going
to get through the system um it's a um
situation that in
553 there's absolutely no requirement to
make those commercial loans or the the
retail loans there's no metric in this
bill to ever find out what happened
there's no reporting back you'll never
know what happened and the reality uh of
the loss of of return uh measured to the
promise of an economic report I think
way in the favor of the cities and towns
who get the money uh the economic report
is intellectually sound it was paid for
by the bankers the numbers extrapolate
but we'll never know what happened so if
you want to put that money out under 553
you will as a finance committee have no
idea where it went or what happened uh
so we think that the bill the pup is
done a great job diversification is the
safety there was comments about fail
pools by the bankers which is very um
you know Works in their favor but here
in New Hampshire that pool has never
lost one cent even in 2008 and even
during the covid crisis where they
continue to make returns now I will let
kha take over as a director of of the
fund uh and give you some of the uh the
details and quickly appreciate all right
thank you everyone for having me here
today so I I just want to answer a
couple of questions so pfm Asset
Management we're in SEC red registered
uh investment advisor and what that
means is is through our contract with
the state to manage the New Hampshire
Public deposit investment pool we do
have a fiduciary uh responsibility to
the beneficiaries of the pool um
additionally there have been a lot of
questions today about collateral and
collateral and FDIC insurance as Mr
Nickerson was just trying to describe
are things that apply to Banks so the
New Hampshire Public deposit investment
pool P dip the pool um it's not a bank
it doesn't operate like a bank uh and it
shouldn't be treated like a bank so
collateral in the state of New Hampshire
can be a variety of things one of those
things that collateral can be is a
portfolio of Securities when you look at
what the pool is investing directly in
and so as as Mr mlin just mentioned when
you invest a dollar into the pool you
become a shareholder and by that way way
you directly invest into Securities so
the pool itself follows not only state
statutes State investment statute but
also the investment policy uh that's
been established through the banking
commissioner originally the state
treasurer currently and an advisory
committee so all of those folks have
input on what the fund can actually
invest in so what those include are all
the same Securities virtually the same
Securities that the banks can today post
the collateral for the account uh so
when you're looking at it from a risk
perspective they're very similar you
wouldn't necessarily so in the pool's
case what you'd be asking if you still
allowed the investment policy to exist
is for the pool to buy a treasury to
secure a treasury uh just simply
wouldn't be the case so I think there's
a couple of unintended consequences of
this bill I don't think the intent of
Senator Rosenwald was necessarily to try
to put the pool out of business as folks
have said uh today but I think it's a
possibility it's a real possibility
because of what Mr Nickerson just said
so when you hire an investment manager
you pay them a fee and that investment
manager can and will go out and
negotiate rates based on what the
investment policy is with those Banks
but the question then becomes is does
that fee additional fee that's paid on
top of that make the pool less
competitive does it in inhibit its
ability to be competitive and we do
think that it will another unintended
consequence here of this bill is that
rather than allowing local towns to
choose you know choose what kind of risk
they're comfortable with uh with their
Investments you're actually imposing
investment restrictions and limitations
on them and additional risks that the
state itself doesn't currently take on
um so those are a couple of the
unintended consequences of this bill as
well so I'd be happy to answer any
questions I'll jump in for one sec one
of the ironies sitting here today is
several weeks ago the bankers and the
baa came in and test of it against House
Bill 1267 which was against diversity in
in the Investments of the of the New
Hampshire retirement system so on that
day they were for diversity and here
they're creating less diversity I think
it's somewhat ironic thank you
representative papovich meller thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for being here
and taking
questions a question about the cost of
the potential
you know the potential cost that would
be imposed on you if we decide to
require you to collateralize or ensure
I'm looking at your uh you know pull of
Investments and it seems that it
Securities with a maximum weight average
maturity to reset of 60 days or less
correct given the very short time you
know the very short age of the portfolio
it doesn't look like that
collateralization should be particularly
expensive for you guys what are your
thoughts on that so again as an
investment Pro product collateralization
is not applicable you're invested
directly into those Securities fly
understood but if the state decided that
its policy is that everything that the
municipality invested has to be
collateralized I'm asking about that you
know if we decide to do that how much of
a cost burden would be that to you in
terms of your ability to secure the type
of collateralization if we required it
so in order to purchase a treasury to
secure a treasury we'd basically have
twice the cost there
because you'd have to buy that same
treasury to secure that same treasury in
that circumstance okay thank
you further questions from committee we
have 12 more people waiting to speak on
this if you're all going to spend two
minutes asking questions we'll be here
two hours more especially when you've
heard some of the questions answered
before
so and right now there's 13 opposed and
five for so thank you very much
and we'll next
call Gregory Heath from Canterbury trust
funds so I'm going to wave my time as my
issues have been addressed thank you
appreciate it very much Carrie CLE from
Coos County
good afternoon chairman Wier and
representatives uh my name is Carrie CLE
and I am the Director of Finance for
Coos County for the past 11 years and
the treasurer for the town of Colombia
for 5 years the county in Colombia
oppose SB 553 as
amended most of the municipalities and
Coos use a mixture of Investments with
New Hampshire P dip and local banks this
combination works well for our
investment needs in rural New Hampshire
I would like to refer to the
commissioner's letter and highlight a
few points we have a a letter that was
written by our County
Commissioners I I believe it was
submitted a cursory review of earned
interest from the New Hampshire Public
investment pool PP Investments by Coos
County municipality shows nearly 500,00
at risk with the biggest exposure to the
county Berlin gorm and
Pittsburgh additionally colbrook earned
$
17,635
Columbia
5,855 dummer
$1,961 arrol $
5,652 Northumberland 14,000 shelburn
13,000 and Stark
25,4 don't do the I'm done that was in
um the those are not inconsequential
amounts for small rural towns in
northern New Hampshire which
unfortunately has the highest poverty
rate in the state of in the state at
133% and a much more challenging tax
base than downstate and this is by no
means allinclusive since this only
includes interest income from some of
the towns and does not include the
school districts but the point of this
is that SB 553 isn't Market oriented it
is anti-competitive and certainly not
the New Hampshire way
if it passes it will in effect neuter
New Hampshire P dip and make it obsolete
in return we are very concerned it will
severely impact the finances of the
county in virtually all the
towns thank you very much I have a
couple more I'll be try to be really
quick make no mistake this was will have
ramifications to
taxpayers there was a clear
rationalization for the establishment of
the P dip and it was proven to work very
effectively for many municipalities
since
1993 if it's not broken why fix it the
Commissioners want to know if the
bankers associ Association or the
legislature will guarantee C County and
its towns a revenue neutral return on
its Investments for the next three years
based on the last three years returns
further there will be a guarantee that
small businesses business loans in Coos
County will increase from this
legislation and how much of the 24
million in increase state and local
revenues in 2025 will be for Coos than
we urge legislation to bring the various
stakeholders together to in study to
committee to determine the efficacy of
the Banker's economic you could leave us
the copies of the written testimony I'll
be sure that everybody sees it thank
you next call on Dave Karen from town of
Derry good afternoon thank you for your
time I did uh email my testimony
committee before noon time I'll just a
couple highlights is that town of der
invest about 25% of its assets in PIP
and the remaining 75 5% stays with six
various Banks either in New Hampshire or
Massachusetts and that bank in mass is
licensed to business in New Hampshire
with pdip rate is about
5.5% the rates we get from the Hampshire
Banks range from 2.92 to
5.37 our weighted average for the other
Banks outside of P dip is
3.98% if p no longer be able to be give
us a competitive rate it would result in
Dairy losing depending upon how you
measure it the next highest bank they
could accept all our deposits or our
weighted average Dairy would lose
between 75,000 and
$521,000 a year based on this
legislation now I understand the study
which was conducted exhorts a a uh a
large return Statewide and that's why
it's fundamentally flawed because what
you have is you have different
communities with different asset size of
through peda
being required to deposit an instate
bank and I'm not an economist what I
know is that when you have over Supply
the price goes down when you have over
demand the price goes up and what our
concern is is that Dairy is a tax cap
and as a town as opposed to the school
in the county I receive 30 I the town
receives 33 cents of every dollar which
we generate so in order to recover my
losses of 75 to
$521,000 we would have to generate an
additional 11 million to $75 million in
property development and just to put
that in perspective when we build our
budget every year we anticipate $20
million in additional development so
therefore our new development to hold
Dairy harmless by having PP no longer
being competitive we'd have to increase
our development by between 50% and
fourfold and so you know again I've got
a more information but you folks can
read and you know I just think that this
legislation is ill advised the process
has worked great for 30 years uh it is
not ceriz we are very comfortable with
that because it is overseen by the state
treasurer and a committee of folks
including members of the bankers
Association as a very conservative uh
conservative investment vehicle uh one
additional request this is a very
important issue and and I appreciate
everybody's Crea creativity talking
about
amendments my
request is that you vote to in expedient
legislate if you don't then please send
it the interim study it's way too
important to with all due respect do
amendments on the Fly not knowing the
total fiscal consequences to our
community thank you for your time thank
you for giving us some solid numbers you
have a question no I just wanted
testim he's WR you have written
testimony you're going to and he said he
sent it to us submit it on your portal
this morning okay it's on the computer
thank you sir thanks so much Todd celik
Town manager from
Dura and the gentleman with
you yes sir my name is Curtis register
I'm a town counselor for the town of dur
have you filled out a pan card pink card
as well no sir I didn't know I need to
fill out a separate one since we're
speaking at the same time thank you
thank you very much members of the
committee I've submitted testimony uh
you have the yellow copies here I
emailed them to as well and I won't
repeat what I've already sent you but I
wanted to just indicate that the town of
durm is very much against this bill we
would agree with my colleague David
Karen from the town of dairy that this
is too important issue to try to adjust
on the fly if there's a desire to do
that we'd recommend you send it to
interim study I want to just paint for
you a picture of what it's like at the
local level many many communities are
very small they have limited resources
they have limited expertise and it's
challenging for them to shop around for
the best interest rate often they also
don't have the size of deposits that are
needed to Garner a high rate unlike the
city of Manchester or nashille perhaps
the city of conquer where you have the
resources and you have the dollars you
can walk into Citizens Bank and say I'd
like a good rate and if you can't you
find a better rate somewhere else for
many of our 234 towns and cities that's
just not the case so the New Hampshire
Public deposit investment pool allows
for a very easy transaction between
inexperienced local officials looking
for a safe place to invest their money
at a high rate of return you heard
earlier from one of the speakers that
there's a moral argument in play here to
invest money in the state of New
Hampshire I would argue on behalf of
localities that the moral argument is to
invest local dollars some are tax uh tax
receipts some are donations the town
might receive some are bequests the town
has received for the Perpetual care of
grave sites cemeteries scholarships some
our Capital Improvement project monies
that have been put aside the fiduciary
responsibility is to find the highest
rate of return in a prudent way and
that's what communities try to do and to
limit that by forcing the communities to
only be able to deal with the banks is a
challenge I think the P dip allows the
performance of that goal to maximize
those local dollars now in terms of the
U projections within the uh Golab study
I have a lot of respect for Brian gotab
he's outstanding I believe that much of
what he's outlined is highly speculative
and I wanted to um read to you an email
that I received today from a uh select
person in the town of uh newfields uh
this is from uh um hold on a
moment I'm sorry Michael sonunu
um right can what what is this
legislation intended to do can it really
be based on a speculative notion that
the banks would reinvest the funds in
New Hampshire businesses and therefore
provide economic benefits beyond the
returns provided by the pool if this was
the case then why do many of the banks
in the state park their excess reserves
in the Federal Reserve System providing
no economic benefit for the state and
why would anyone believe that providing
them with hundreds of millions of
dollars in deposits taken from the pool
wouldn't result in those Banks
evaluating the risk return on investing
those funds and doing what they do with
their excess funds now in fact as
fiduciaries the bank managers and board
members have capital letters to take
that into consideration and won't
automatically just open the spigots for
local businesses and if there are better
ways to put those funds to work they
will buy MBS as us treasuries or deposit
the funds in a bank in another state
that is providing an excellent interest
rate remember too that these funds are
fungible and that once put into the
banks you'll have no way of ensuring
that the pool funds are turned into the
local loans or if they are the deposits
used to buy more us treasuries I'd also
note that to the extent that
municipalities are able to maximize the
rate of return that's all money we put
back into our local communities so if
you allow the pool to maximize the rate
it empowers municipalities school
districts uh Trustees of the trust funds
Etc to reinvest back in their local
communities and that I anticipate would
drive the same level of business um if
you have any question questions I'd be
happy to answer them thank you very much
appreciate you
coming representative Edwards thank you
Mr chair I I I want to come back around
to your comfort level professionally
with um the risk that's uh that that
this fund is currently exposed to are
you satisfied that uh that the the the
riskiness of the Investments of these
funds um let you sleep at night or or is
it does it exceed your risk tolerance
they they allow us to sleep at night the
the it was the banking commissioner
until a year ago I believe and now the
New Hampshire treasure assisted by other
board members established by Statute who
manage that pool they do a very good job
and I actually wrote to uh the fund
manager who you heard from earlier today
with a series of questions and I have
her responses in the yellow packet that
I've provided but thank you very much I
I asked about this issue of
collateralization and her answer was
there's no requirement nor should there
be to collateralize investments in the
in the pool simply because of the direct
nature of the Investments a purchase of
securities issued by the United States a
federal agency commercial paper Etc
differs from Bank deposits and that nhp
dip and investors by way of the pool the
municipalities own the security itself
collateralization of Bank deposits are
required because of the uncertainty
regarding the ability of the banks to
always have cash on hand or the ability
to make cash available for your
withdrawals funds deposited into the
banks are either loaned out or invested
in the bank's own accounts the
Securities Banks invest in are the same
generally kinds of Securities that the
pool invests in thank you thank you
thank you no further questions we'll
next call on representative Jim I think
it's tney from
Ron sorry I didn't realize there was a
rep here
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
for hearing my testimony I would like
first to correct one thing that uh the
treasurer from or the finance officer
from Coos County said uh gron
Northumberland uh on one account made
that
$14,600 figure she said the total amount
on all funds invested in PIP exceeded
$100,000
that the town
made okay uh as far as P dip goes it's
an investment just like any investment
any of youve got in mutual funds it is
perfectly safe at this time yes if
there's a meltdown in the stock market
around the world yep we will suffer a
loss but so will everybody else uh we
have no problems with this at all and I
liked car's uh statement if it ain't
broke don't fix it
thank that's all I got appreciate brev
thank you
okay uh Timothy L I think it's Rucker
from Kean school district and if I said
your name wrong please sure apologize
and correct me thank you uh chairman
Wayman and all the representatives I'm
Tim Tim Roar um handwriting Is Not Great
uh but I've been doing I'm so I'm a CFO
at uh keing School District I represent
a number of districts I'll try to be
brief and not go over what everybody has
said there's been a number of good
points but I think I have a perspective
that will help one of the things that
that make the information that's coming
out suspect to me is that in reality I
used the I've used the pool on and off
since uh
2001 um five years ago you would have
seen my balance at zero their rates were
terrible now you'll see my balance is
about $7 million rates are pretty good
uh my balance for one of the school
districts that I uh
oversee um but every dime that goes
through P dip eventually goes through my
bank so there's not 600 million extra
there's 600 million currently but most
of those funds will eventually run
through a bank to be spent and become
part of the deposits in a bank so this
assumption that it's an additional 600
million is not true it it there are some
funds I leave in there you know people
have Cemetery funds that stay in there
for a long time but to spend them it's
not a bank they're all going through
they're they're reaping the rewards from
those deposits eventually but also that
interest rates are the same I have a lot
of bargaining power I have districts
with no bargaining power this was
created to give us we don't have a Level
Playing Field if this was your money if
you were putting 75 million through your
personal account would you like New
Hampshire to tell you you can only use a
bank
you would lose out on lots of money and
in this case that's what we're talking
about they created a small little
riskier pool so that we can get returns
of taxpayers money for taxpayers for us
it means for Keen alone this year no
projections I would lose
$300,000 that would directly go to
taxpayers through property tax I was
able to lower the property tax ask by
$300,000 of tax rate setting that I
would not and I'm going to go tell them
but don't worry you're going to have I'm
raising that next year but don't worry
it's going to be vested in New Hampshire
you'll be fine I mean this is this pool
was created by a very smart body like
yourselves to help us to help the
taxpayer and to shoot ourselves in the
foot for the name of helping New
Hampshire is not smart that's all I have
to say thank you thank you very much for
your
brevity all right next call Annette
Marquee town of
Carol thank you for your time um I lot
of my testimony has already been given
but I'm Anette Marquee from the town of
Carol I'm the treasurer um and I'm
speaking on behalf of myself and our
three Selectmen that we oppose this bill
um um I won't reiterate a lot of what's
said I certainly agree but I'm here to
give a reality check on the first item
we heard them talk about IC accounts
where they sweep money out over the
250,000 when I look at my bank statement
every month and they sweep our excess
money out it goes to about 20 different
banks not one of those Banks is located
in New Hampshire not one
the second thing that I want to testify
to is we talk about the leverage that
the pool gives us to negotiate loans and
to negotiate interest
rates well our school has a $24 million
budget that goes through one
account my town has a budget of $7
million I used the pool and I received
for the town
$150,000 in interest this year the
school does not use the pool they use
one bank and they got
$4,700 oh last year they got
$2,200 it gives us leverage please don't
take away our leverage thank you very
much all right let's hear from a couple
of people who support the bill Dave juv
from the Bia
thank you Mr chair for the record my
name is Dave juv I'm a senior vice
president with the business and industry
Association we represent uh State
employers here at the legislature we are
here in favor of this bill um there's
been a lot of comments uh from those
opposing it saying if it ain't broke
don't fix it those of us who support
this legislation are not suggesting
something's broken and needs to be fixed
we're suggesting that there's a lot of
money that would be available to uh
create economic development in New
Hampshire that is not currently doing so
uh that's my simple Point you'll be
happy to hear I have written testimony
that I will leave with the assistant
thank you you testified often enough to
know how it
works Clay Adams from masoma Bank
thank you Mr chairman I will I have
submitted written testimony and I will
not read it uh but I will just make a
few points based on the conversation
that's happened here today uh Mascoma is
a New Hampshire chartered institution
based in Lebanon we $3 billion do in
assets with over 400 people and most of
our operations are in New Hampshire but
we also operate in Vermont and Maine and
I think that gives me a unique
perspective to be able to offer that the
deposit environment in those states that
do not have investment pools is high
highly competitive uh we see that even
more so in some of those States in
certain places uh even uh more so paying
rates higher than the than the pool is
currently offering in New Hampshire so I
think the fair market works very well
even in the absence of of a pool which
is not what the bankers Association is
saying should happen um and so therefore
what I would argue is that given that
competitiveness the the numbers you were
hearing cited from municipalities are
not going to drop to zero the return is
still going to be be there uh and it and
in addition to that return it will allow
us as Banks to continue funding very
solid loans as representative Maguire
inquired not the that there is more
demand for than there is capital today
and not marginal loans uh we see that
throughout our market and uh I I can I
can attest that that is critically
important on the matter of IC um we are
a big uh uh user of that service it it
was created by a gentleman named Jane
lwig who was the former comp troller of
the currency for the US uh it is I would
say a sophisticated product that allows
us to um participate in these reciprocal
deposits so yes they are held by Banks
from around the country but we hold
their reciprocating deposits with us
which allows us to put those dollars to
work in New Hampshire they are not being
held by someone else and invested
elsewhere they're being invested locally
um that I think is critically important
to understand the other thing that I
think is an important point and we have
dozens and dozens of Municipal customers
and hundreds of millions of dollars on
deposit with them we as a Community Bank
operate and compete on on price but also
service and what we find with many of
those municipalities of all varieties
and levels of government is that some
are are absolutely rate seeking
maximizing people others need it for
other reasons they need flexibility so
there are municipalities or or levels of
government that want to have operating
accounts where there's quick access that
is not a high rate in uh uh uh fund just
as we as consumers wouldn't you would
have a checking account and a savings
account those that are more rate seeking
work with us and their local banks to
find how do I maximize my rate and PP is
always out there and that is hanging
right over our heads less the cost of
what it cost us to ensure these deposits
uh to make sure that they are safe um so
I think those are some of the points
that that I would like to make and I
just want to thank you for your time
your consideration of this
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for the question just to clarify what
you first said are you suggesting that
the non-time deposit interest rates paid
in Maine and Vermont exceed the rates
paid by the we see that in some places
yes so those are those are states
without pools when you say some places
can you be more specific I think you
might see it in more urban areas like a
Portland or a Burlington than you would
in in other areas where there are just
more financial institutions that's not
to say that we're not serving our other
smaller communities uh equally as well
thank you thank you sir y further
questions seeing none next next here
from Dan Lynch city of Dober opposing
the
bill good afternoon arm chairman wer
it's been a little bit of time since
I've testified in front of you and
members of the house finance committee
I'm Dan Lynch I currently have 32 years
of combined experience in New Hampshire
Municipal and government Finance I was
working in the town of marac I started
in February
1992 so I've been using the pool since
its Inception I've used it in marac I've
used it in Raymond and currently I'm the
finance director in the city of do and
we use it there through the pool last
year our fiscal year 2023 we generated
almost a million dollars from our
investments in the pool that's about 33
cents on our tax rate if you're in favor
of increasing property tax at the local
level then vote for this
bill because that's what's going to
happen I don't know any other way to
look at it the pred benefits of the
proposed legislation are speculative at
best to my knowledge the report by
polyon has never been vetted by a
municipality County School District to
say hey what's the offsetting impact of
doing
this there's no obligations noted in 553
to require the banks to make loans spur
this supposed economic benefit that the
polycon report
perpetuates the likelihood is that
municipalities the bigger municipalities
like do Manchester and ASA will seek to
Direct Banking relationships in Louis
pet and over we were already talking
about that before this bill came forward
and once the bill came forward we said
okay we're going to hold off and see
what's going
on once the Corpus of the pp becomes too
small the pool will cease to exist
economically it just won't be
viable you have to note that there's 10
depositors in the pool that represent
close to 50% of the
pool one of those I can pretty guarantee
is the state and I can tell you a second
one is the city of
Dover so if this if this passes the city
of do I'm recommending to the city
manager and the council we go out on our
own again and we maybe we pull with a
couple other communities to get better
rates so now what happens the pools
cease to
exist what's the impact of State
Treasury
operations state treasur
provides almost all of the money from
the state to municipalities through the
P di so almost every Community was
required to set up a pip account there's
no checks generated anymore it's all
electronically done what would be the
fees to go back to issuing checks or the
fees that would be generated in a
regular banking relationship for wire
transfers there are no fees in
pedp let's take a few seconds because I
know times of the essence how do we go
from 250 million in the pool all of a
sudden to 600 million well in the last
two years there's been a huge influx of
what everybody calls Opa money
communities don't have to rush out the
door to spend that they have to obligate
it by this December 31st and then they
have two more years to spend that so
let's take ARA out of the equation that
drops that 600 million let's talk about
Trustees of trust fund
what they can invest in they have
capital reserve funds and they have
trust funds they can invest with a bank
or brokerage firm to establish their own
little investment direct buyings and and
and results so that further arose that
600 million and in the scheme of things
if this bill was to pass you'd probably
be back to about that $250 million range
maybe even less what's what's the
economic benefit
I will provide my written comments to
the LBA clerks appreciate good to seeing
you again good to see
you questions from the committee last
card I have is from Aubrey
fredman thank you for your
patience i f it up for
499 ah we're done I see that wait I see
the treasurer did she wish to comment
testimony
questions anyone have any questions for
our
Treasurer representative Maguire would
like to ask you a
question and I have several
Pages thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Madame treasurer for coming good
afternoon um how is it that you choose
uh the place that this money gets
invested or the the manager of the
fund uh it is in statute that we need to
issue an RFP to to select the advisor
that was prior to my time that was done
by the banking Department uh in 2020
when that was uh the last time we we had
um when that contract was uh was
established with with the current
adviser yeah follow so that's every five
years or something like that yes yes I'm
sorry yes thank
you Mr chair
all right uh any further questions
representative papichi thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here and for
being willing to answer questions when
is the um current contract
expiring yes so that um so um the
amendment we I work with with the Senate
with Senator renell on the amendment uh
because that's
um now the the bill um has the time
of if Bill were this bill were to pass
uh it will the pro the new program will
start on June 2020 or 25 that's when the
contract expires um so the the bill
right now is as amended is is is the
signed that if this bill were to pass we
will be we will have about a year to to
work on finding uh essentially is RFP to
try to find um an investment advisor
that will be able to to to run this
program with the current
requirements um and if we can't find an
advisor that is able to do that then um
then we'll come back to you to um
perhaps readjust the Bill thank you
thank you madam
Treasurer all right I have the signup
sheet uh some of these people have have
already
testified thank you madam treasure my
pleasure I'll be happy to come back and
and and answer additional questions or
there may be someone that goes to
division one thank you perfect thank you
okay so interesting the the pink
cards I think I
counted um five for and 12
against with the signup sheet it was 23
for and 12
against so we're about where we were
before this is a very
puzzling proposal I thank you all for
your attendance we'll close the hearing
and and uh it will be be going again I
think May 7th to division 1 for further
testimony
okay so now um as soon as we clear out a
little bit we have Senate Bill
499 which I said I'd begin at 3:30 but
it's a little later than that
so Senate Bill
499 has Senator Whitley come back yes
very good all
right so we'll open the hearing on
Senate Bill 499 and recognize Senator
Whitley to introduce the Bill thank you
Mr chair and good afternoon members of
the committee it's been a long afternoon
for you for the record my name is Becky
Whitley I'm honored to represent
district 15 which you're sitting in
right now the wonderful city of
conquered and the surrounding towns of
bow and hackington today I'm proud to
introduce to you the bipartisan
hunger-free New Hampshire act Senate
Bill
499 so um I'm also passing around sort
of a a cheat sheet for you this is a
comprehensive Bill to address hunger in
New Hampshire so I wanted to you to have
this cheat
sheet so just to put this bill into
context I would say on equivocally that
there are a few issues that keep me up
at night more than food insecurity in
our state it really does seem
unimaginable to me in a state like ours
but far too many people in New Hampshire
just do not have enough food for
themselves or their families in October
2023 over half of New Hampshire family
of New Hampshire children and 44% of
adults living in households that
reported having insufficient Foods
that's staggering no one have to wonder
where their next meal will come from yet
far too many Granite Staters have to
choose between food and other critical
needs like medicine electricity or even
child care I would ask that for a moment
you put yourselves in the shoes of a
parent who has to put their children to
bed
hungry as the parent of a 10-year-old I
can't even imagine that
feeling or put yourselves in the shoes
of an elderly parent or grandparent who
has worked their entire life
yet struggles to make ends meet and has
to choose between a roof over their head
and
groceries we simply can't ignore that
hunger is happening in New
Hampshire but I would say that we are
not helpless to solve this problem we
know how to fix the problem of hunger
and food insecurity we just need the
political will to make that happen the
bill before you today includes a
comprehensive set of measures to reduce
food insecurity for children people with
disabilities and older adults in New
Hampshire and this is smart policy
because it will support our schools
leverage federal dollars which support
New Hampshire's local
economy and invest in New Hampshire's
economic
future the first step in this process is
ensuring that everyone who is eligible
for existing Federal nutrition programs
is actually enrolled unfortunately the
way we're doing things in New Hampshire
now is leaving too many of our neighbors
including children older adults people
with disabilities just disconnected from
the resources that already exists to
help them this bill before you the
hunger-free New Hampshire act would help
to feed more children meals in school
and help to ensure that they are not
hungry during the
summer it would also help more older
adults and people with disabilities to
connect to programs that help them avoid
food
insecurity by making mod Investments to
leverage federal dollars and by removing
barriers we absolutely can end Hunger in
New Hampshire this comprehensive
anti-hunger legislation was crafted to
remove barriers to streamline program
Administration and increased
participation in this critical n
nutrition program I want to thank the
Departments of education and health and
human services for all of their work on
behalf of New Hampshire children and
families and adults with disabilities
and for their partnership in this work
this bill has gone through extensive
work in the Senate you will see that is
very different than as introduced we
were we were very thoughtful about
prioritizing those areas that were most
critical and identifying the sources of
funding for those particular programs I
am not the expert in these various
programs there are certainly folks
behind me that can speak to the
importance and impact of these programs
and why these some additional modest
funds are necessary to leverage the
additional dollars with that said I am
happy to take questions and look forward
to a continued conversation on Senate
Bill 499 thank you thank you Senator
representative papichi M thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Senator Whitley
for being here um I just am trying to
understand the lifl let in front of me
States a certain number of children in
our state that face hunger is that the
number of children that that are um
considered to be food
insufficient so that is data that um was
T you're talking about the over half of
New Hampshire
children one in 12 so that is data that
is data that um has been provided by the
by various surveys at the federal level
New Hampshire hunger Solutions is here
and they they are the ones that do a lot
of that collection of that data and they
have on their website sort of I will
then reserve my so I think with them
better to speak to the data thank you
very much for that thank you
yeah further questions from the
committee repres representative Edwards
thank you Mr chair uh it's good seeing
you again Senator um so I I wonder if
you think your bill goes far enough
because you've identified one of the
social determinants of of Health uh food
which is vital there are other social
determinants of Health too you mentioned
electricity as as a tradeoff families
are making MH there's uh prescriptions
housing clothing Transportation
shouldn't we be doing those things also
if we're going to be responsible for
feeding everyone during the summer
through the school system thank you I
mean you know of course there are
priorities that families have to make
and there are priorities that this legis
legislature has to make and to me you
know making sure that children are fed
seems like a basic need in my
opinion thank you for the question
further questions from
committee thank you Senator thank you
very much next call Aubrey fredman from
BridgeWalk how that I read your number
right Mr chairman committee members uh
Aubrey Friedman from Bridgewater I speak
in opposition to this bill uh my main a
few reasons but my main thing is this is
parents when you are responsible for for
kids providing food is one of your basic
responsibilities and we already have the
and the problem with these government
programs is when you start them it
started off the lunch program then it's
breakfast and the co they kind of you
know gave it to everybody so that's a
different thing now we're going into the
summer adding the summer they expand and
expand do parents not need I'm surprised
they don't have dinner maybe that'll be
coming next if you think about it
there's no end to it parents if you are
taking Char if you choose to have
children or maybe some family situation
occurs where you are U you're going to
be guardians or whatever it's your
responsibility to provide for the needs
of your family and you've taken that on
and that's your response not your
neighbors it's not taxpayers it's yours
this bill expands on
uh it's making people it would would
make uh families more dependent on
government we should be working the
opposite to have people to be more
independent more self-sufficient and to
be able to be Su successful enough to
provide for your family so it moves in
the wrong direction that's the first
thing now as far as cost the state part
of it there's a state part and a federal
part the state part it's coming from
taxes so tax tax other tax taxpayers are
going to be paying for it which makes it
it more expensive for everybody the
federal
part that's the inflation tax the
federal government is is pushing 35
trillion in the negative and and
increasing all the time so if it's
federal dollars they're not free it's
taxpayer it's actually all the citizens
of the United States are contributing to
that there's not nothing free here uh
okay
now the thing with the school uh lunches
and all that from what I've heard
there's actually a lot of food is
actually thrown away because the kids
don't like it so the thing is if you pay
for it your parents pay for it you are
going to be more responsible and less
likely to waste it it makes me think of
like going to a buffet you don't pay
anymore if you fill up your plates so
people tend to kind of leave some but if
if you're paying for it exactly you're
not going to waste it so that's how I
see the expansion of this program it's
going there's going to be a lot of waste
and from what I've heard of our like our
student rep at the school board meetings
she complained about our the school
meals there and that the kids don't like
it and they're throwing it away not all
the time but I think there would this
would be encouraging waste and lastly I
think actually childhood obesity is a
bigger problem than hunger yes there is
hunger in New Hampshire there's poverty
there's no question but we have churches
we have food banks where uh people can
go and that's voluntarily
given uh you know donations that's the
better way people feel more grateful and
not like when it becomes a government
benefit then it becomes like an
entitlement or eventually a right it's a
right to food so those are the problems
I see with this bill and that's why I I
oppose it thank you Mr fredman are there
questions from committee members seeing
none thank thank you thank you next call
Megan
brabeck from new
mark thank you chairman on Ro committee
members my name is Megan brabeck I live
in New Market New Hampshire and I'm here
today representing the thousands of save
the children Action Network supporters
across the state scan is the advocacy
arm of save the children and we are are
building bipartisan support to make sure
that every child has a strong start in
life and that includes working to end
Hunger right here in New Hampshire and
across the
country I think we all agree that no
child should go hungry in our state and
voters agree with that as well in 2022
scan conducted polls of rural voters in
which they shared that food prices are
one of the biggest problems facing their
families um and in the written testimony
I've linked to that poll so you can see
that in more depth online
um half of all of the parents pulled
said that they are struggling to afford
food for their family and a majority of
the voters pulled stated that they are
worried that they might not be able to
afford enough food to feed themselves
and their family over the next year and
census data that has been mentioned um
that's been shared by uh New Hampshire
hunger Solutions shows the same story
finding that 42% of New Hampshire
children lived in households that
reported having insufficient
food hunger is devastating for growing
minds and bodies
malnutrition stunts more than kids
development it stunts their Futures as
well hungry children are more likely to
struggle in class repeat a grade or miss
school entirely without enough to eat
they may never reach their full
potential when children can grow up
healthier and stronger our economy and
our nation grow healthier and stronger
as well s SP 499 is a comprehensive and
bipartisan anti-hunger legislation that
will benefit folks across the state I'm
here to advocate for the granite state
kids who will be impacted by the
legislation
firstly this bill will improve
participation in school breakfast
programs according to a 2023 report from
the food research and action center
95,3 37 New Hampshire students ate
School provided lunch in the 2122 school
year but fewer than half of those
students also participated in a school
breakfast which puts us in the bottom 16
states in the country for
this this bill will address the issue by
requiring schools with free and reduced
percentages above 10% to offer breakfast
at school it also incentivizes the
breakfast after the Bell program which
allows kids to pick up breakfast and eat
it during their first class giving them
more time to eat increasing
participation in school breakfast brings
in more federal dollars to support
feeding
kids the second way this bill approaches
child hunger is by ensuring access to
school meals it requires schools to
allow online applications which is
helpful for busy parents it also uses
additional reimbursements as an
incentive for schools to partip in the
federal reimbursement programs making it
really an investment in childhood uh
nutrition and lastly as mentioned uh it
would require the state to participate
in summer EBT which enhances access to
food in between school years please vote
a to pass if you agree that every child
deserves access to nutritious meals
Granite State kids are worth the
investment I'm happy to take questions
although I do think some of my
colleagues in the back may be able to
answer more of the specifics
representative Maguire for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
coming can you describe the summer
program a little bit more exactly how
does that get food to students um I'm
going to defer that to some of my
colleagues who are more familiar with
the the nuances of the different
programs sorry I'm happy to look it up
though if if they can't
answer thank you for your testimony
thanks so
much next call on Sam Hawkins from
namami New
Hampshire two minutes good afternoon
chairman members of the committee thank
you for the opportunity to testify today
my name is Sam Hawkins I'm the public
policy assistant at Nami New Hampshire
the National Alliance on Mental Illness
Nami New Hampshire is a nonprofit
Grassroots organization whose mission is
to improve the lives of all people
impacted by mental illness and suicide
through support education and advocacy
on behalf of Nami New Hampshire I'm here
today to speak in support of Senate Bill
499 a variety of complex factors
contribute to an individual's mental
health but one key determinant is food
security and hunger when our basic needs
are not met it makes it more difficult
to maintain all aspects of our health
including our mental health in children
especially the connection between hunger
and mental health is clear a study
published by the American Academy of
Pediatrics found that severe hunger is
associated with higher reported anxiety
and depression among school-aged
children including reported rates of
anxiety nearly double of that of
children with no hunger just as food's
insecurity may affect mental health
one's mental health can also impact
their ability to work and afford food
for themselves and their families
research by the Department of
Agriculture found that adults with a
mental health disability are up to five
times more likely to live in a household
that is food
insecure by addressing food insecurity
and other social determinants of Health
we have the opportunity to ensure that
individuals and their families have the
chance to get and stay well s499 does
just that for these reasons nomin New
Hampshire urges the committee to
recommend OTP for Senate Bill 499 thank
you thank you and you have written
testimony to leave with us appreciate it
questions from committee represent hichi
thank you
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for being here to testify um could you
explain to me the difference between
hunger and for
insecurity uh thank you very much for
your question um I will defer that
question to hunger Solutions I think I
will be happy answer that thank
you further from the committee well
since you've nominated that person we'll
call on next laa milin from New
Hampshire hunger solution thank you very
much
we're all working together
right yes
so uh good afternoon chairman wer and
members of the committee um my name is
Laura milikin I am the executive
director of New Hampshire hunger
solution we're a nonpartisan nonprofit
uh organization advocating to end Hunger
in the state um and uh I think that
you've heard from others here that um
hunger is high in the state right now
Rising food housing and child care costs
and many other costs are straining
budgets of granite sters and making too
many people food
insecure s499 invests General funds to
leverage a high number of federal
dollars to uh try to solve hunger and
they'll have a positive effect on New
Hampshire's economy because uh
the particularly for snap the dollars
are
provided they can only be spent for food
they're spent in the local economy the
return on investment is high there are
three pieces that are currently funded
in the bill so the first is enabling
children currently in the federal
reduced price lunch category those are
children with whose families incomes are
between 130 and 185% of the federal
poverty level those children would eat
free meals so for context 185% of the
federal poverty level means a family of
three with a monthly income of
$3,833 right now at New Hampshire the
median rent for a two-bedroom apartment
is
$1,764 or 46% of that income the median
cost of child care for a family uh with
an infant is
$1,140 a month and that's 29% of the
income of somebody who's uh at 185% of
poverty so you can see how am might have
a hard time paying for meals that leaves
very little of their income for things
like Transportation utilities internet
clothes
um so this bill in uh invests a
relatively small amount to be sure that
folks under 185% of poverty their
children can eat free meals at
school the second part is enabling the
state's participation in summer EVT and
there was a question about how that
works so uh it's a new federal program
the way that it works is that families
whose children are eligible for free and
reduced meals which is also under 185%
of
poverty um the federal poverty level
would get a an EBT card just like
snap um they could use those benefits
only to buy food it's $40 per child per
month for each of the three summer
months so it's 20 uh dollars per child
per
summer um and those are just like Snap
those are dollars that are immediately
reinvested in the local economy they're
spent only on food at the grocery store
or other other local
stores
um the uh um just skipping over things
that have already been said so um and
I've provided in the uh information that
I've passed out um some estimates on the
likely return on investment um based on
the new dollars coming in on summer EBT
um so we're talking about4 a. half
million dollar based on the number of
kids who are currently in free and
reduced price meals we're talking about4
and a. half million dollars of federal
dollars that new federal dollars that
would come into the state um and the
USDA estimates a return on investment on
those dollars of between one and a half
and
$180 per dollar invested in snap and
summer EBT would be the
same the third piece that is funded in
this in the amendment is enabling New
Hampshire's participation in the usda's
elderly simplified application project
and this would make it easier for people
over 60 or people living with
disabilities on fixed incomes to connect
to the snap program it has very low
administrative costs and in fact other
states report that it that it actually
reduces State administrative costs once
implemented because people have to uh
recertify less frequently people on
fixed incomes incomes don't change so
they can recertify less frequently and
less administrative cost also um other
states have told us that when uh they
started the program more folks who are
eligible for SNAP but not currently
enrolled enroll in the program so that
also brings additional federal dollars
into the State and I provided some
estimates about what the return on
investment would
be um so there are some other pieces in
the bill that are not funded at uh at
currently they they you can see that
they're funded at um $1 un less federal
dollars are
available um so the bill really is about
connecting eligible people to snap
bringing in federal dollars um and and
sumary EBT which works just the same as
snap um and uh helping folks who are
having a very tough time uh under 185%
of poverty uh feed their
kids so um again every dollar spent on
SNAP benefits generates a150 to A180 and
economic activity and every dollar spent
on School meals is estimated to have a
return of
$2 uh the bill makes modest Investments
to leverage substantial federal dollars
and provide a high return on investment
so I urge you to vote on to pass on 499
and I'll take questions thank you sir
much repres papichi M for you already
know what I want to ask I can't wait
thank you I mean I already asked it I
thought you were listening but for the
record could you explain the difference
between people who are dealing with
hunger and people who are categorized as
food insufficient
please So Hunger is uh and these are not
you know I I'm not making these up um
people there are lots they're REM of of
uh writing on the subject hunger is
generally thought to be a feeling that
that all of us have had at some time
food insecurity is the sense that you're
not going to be able to have enough food
or enough uh nutritious food I um am
happy to provide and I think you've been
sent the our explanation of the census
household pulse data which is what we
report on our website which uh ask
people people whether they've had enough
to eat in the last seven days or enough
of the right kinds of food if I may
follow up
follow as I expressed in previous
hearings on the topic while dealing
dealing with not having enough food is a
serious issue the state should
absolutely absolutely you know do what
it can to make sure that we do not have
those issues food insufficiency seems to
be a category that includes people who
are dealing with not enough food and
people who and I quote Loosely because I
don't have it in front of me the federal
definition used by the census people to
be people who may have enough food but
they just don't have the kinds of food
they like would that be a reasonable
representation of that definition so we
don't have to go to the website I I
don't think that that is a reasonable I
I think that it's true that the question
is enough of the but it's not the kinds
of foods they like it's the kinds of of
food that meet their nutritional needs
so you know I mean I think we're talking
about the there are follow-up questions
on the census pulse they ask people why
they didn't have enough of the right
kinds of food and they said and many of
them say that it's because they couldn't
afford to buy more food so I think what
is meant by that is that they're eating
instant Ramen instead of fruits and
vegetables we're talking about people's
uh nutritional well-being across the
board and not just whether they actually
have something to put in their
mouths I will yield the floor for a
little bit while I go to the proper
website so we have the accurate language
in front of us thank you represent Hull
for a question thank you madam chair
sorry thank you Mr chair I apologize so
someone handed out this sheet here
relative to
s499 um and it makes the claim that
almost 22,000 children currently are
facing hunger is do you rep is that an
an accurate number thank you for the
question I believe that that was passed
out by Senator Whitley um and she uh
told me that that is from feeding
America they have a a map the meal Gap
site um those those uh that shows what
the okay the numbers are those are I and
I'm G to get this wrong because um I'm
not
uh so
that's I think that's based on the
official food insecurity measure that's
um and I'll I'll send the committee the
the explanation that explains the
difference between food insufficiency
and food insecurity because it is
confusing it is that would be helpful
because being hungry right is a feeling
food insecurity still might be in some
part a feeling but insufficient food
meaning bmis that are below 15 or below
for right 16 somewhere in that range
where the person is is
clearly malnourished is a very different
metric and I want to if we have 22,000
kids in the state that are malnourished
I we should know about that and you guys
should provide that
data sure yeah um so we have been
tracking the census household pulse data
which uh asked the questions that I
talked about with um representative
papuchi Muller because um because those
are almost real time data people are uh
it's an an online survey that is done
monthly um there was a gap this winter
when the census was revamping it but it
started up again in February um and so
that's what we've been tracking it's not
that the other data aren't useful they
are but they tend to be time
lagged so so back to this large group or
potentially large group we're talking
roughly 17th or thereabouts of the
current School population in the state
got about 165,000 kids so uh roughly
17th 1/8 that's one out of every eight I
would be very concerned if one out of
every eight kids is lacking lacking
lacking substance and are is
malnourished so let's use terms that are
like definitive in nature right
malnourished is a is a real category
right feeling hungry is a is a real
category but one requires interaction
one might not yeah I mean I think that
you know I I I wish we had a way of G of
reaching out to families and finding out
you know who's hungry who's being uh
turned away at school who's uh you know
having a hard time concentrating at
school because they can't eat and we
don't have those data what we have is
the census pulse household pulse data
and then we have the um the American
Community survey data which is a little
bit lagged which is I think what is the
basis for um feeding America's uh uh
food insecurity numbers so I mean we do
have data that shows that there are
hungry children in New Hampshire that
there are families that are having a
hard time making ends
meet so that's what I would
say
okay oh
I I I was after reper
ski see I think I've got represent wner
represent I'll go to the end of the line
okay I'll be very quick I'll be very
quick I guess just to Branch off of what
representative H said wouldn't you say
the point of this legislation is to meet
children before they are malnourished
and before they get to that point of
major Health crisis and that's what the
point of this is I would thank you thank
you represent wner question thank you
could you talk a little bit about um the
part of this bill that deals with the
elderly and the SNAP benefit um how many
adults now elderly adults now or
disabled adults now or on Snap uh what
do we anticipate this might do and what
does it mean that the department shall
apply
for so the elderly simple thank you for
the question representative um the
elderly simplified application project
is a set of waivers through the the US
Department of Agriculture um that uh
allow for a different recertification
timing a different um for for people on
fixed incomes who are uh over 60 or are
living with disabilities so the thinking
is that because those folks uh incomes
don't change they shouldn't have to
research certify as often as other
people on snap that makes it easier for
the the uh the state to administer the
program um they still have to report if
their income does change by the way they
um but assuming that it does not change
then they recertify less frequently
every three years so that uh both makes
it easier for administration for the
state and it makes it easier for people
who are living with fixed income comes
to stay on the program if if uh as they
need
to a followup so uh we have to get a
waiver from um Health and Human Services
the
federal my understanding is that it's an
application for the program um that that
New Hampshire would uh would have to but
I but I assume that my colleagues from
DHHS would would be able to answer that
question better than
I
okay represent
thank you Mr chair this legislation is
really important for my city of
Manchester
um we have growing numbers of elderly
citizens who are finding their way
actually into homeless shelters because
the cost of rent is so high and for them
it's almost impossible for them to U try
and and negotiate rents and try and pay
for any kind of food
so again this would be absolutely
necessary in terms of what's most near
and de of my heart are my schools in
Meester and the number of schools who
pretty much reach um about between 95
and almost 100% um children who are
eligible for free and reduced lunch
meals and this bill would be so
important because it would bring to them
possibility of something to eat during
the summer and it's so critical because
one of the things as an educator we
always worried about the most was what
happens to these children in the summer
because there's nobody to bring them
food but from what I in from the
research um if we don't pass this bill
is it true that we'd leave
37,325 children on free and reduced
lunch meals in New Hampshire without
food during the summer months thank you
for the question that is the number of
children children currently uh on the
free and reduced meals um and there
isn't currently a program that that
meets their needs directly um there are
some summer meal programs throughout the
state um but they are there are
definitely Geographic gaps um this
program because it would uh send an EVT
card directly to the family um would
would more directly ensure that families
are able to feed their kids in the
summer just want to thank you and
Senator Whitley for working on this bill
together I think it's just so important
and I'm sure the city of nashar is has
many of the same circumstances that we
see in the city of Manchester thank you
thank you Senator Edwards for a question
then we're waiting to hear from the food
bank and also from the Department of
Health and Human thank you Mr chair I I
just I I just want to uh let people know
that on April 23rd at 1:00 we're going
to have a working session on this it's
going to be a combined session with the
division 3 and div division 2 uh and and
and Mr Ripple I I propose that we do the
first 30 minutes of it um just looking
at this fiscal note because this fiscal
note just confuses me I cannot interpret
it and so before we get into the rust of
the bill and the value of the bill I I I
just want to understand the money that's
here and I don't think this witness is
here to tell us about the money or if
there's anyone here but I'm really
confused by this fcal note so so that
that's for the committee and that's for
you know what I think we're going to we
need to do to break this
down sure and just so the committee
knows there will be yet another version
of the fiscal Note coming out because it
was amended by the Senate twice and the
one you had before you only reflects the
first of those amendments so there'll be
a new version coming out this afternoon
or tomorrow morning thank and Mr chair
um I would be perfectly happy to defer
some of these questions for that uh you
know work session if a New Hampshire
hunger solution will be there just to
respect how late it is in the day and
the fact that we do and plus I want to
give you a fair heads up of exactly what
I'm looking to ask so we have plenty of
time to prepare and you know we can get
everything answered and you know
clarified so I'll you know I'll be happy
to defer until then thank you all right
there's no further questions thank you
for your testimony we look forward to
you on APR
23rd uh next one from the New Hampshire
Food Bank I'm not quite able to read the
last name is it Tiffany
SWAT got it right yes that's
correct welcome good afternoon everyone
my name is Tiffany sweat and I'm the
culinary and nutrition programs director
at the New Hampshire Food Bank thank you
for the opportunity to speak today in
support of SB 499 the New Hampshire food
bank as many of you are probably aware
is a program of Catholic Charities New
Hampshire and is the only food bank in
the state we work with more than 400
partner agencies to provide food and
resources to our neighbors facing food
insecurity over the years I've seen or
we've seen at the food bank a growing
number of partner agencies looking to
meet the increasing demand for emergency
food resources in their community in
2023 we distributed 16.3 million pounds
of food throughout the state a number
that continues to grow each year as part
of the charitable food system we rely on
generous private donation
and grant funding um in order to operate
which poses limitations to the growing
need that we're seeing in the state
according to feeding America I'm going
to throw out a couple statistics too
sorry some of them you've heard um but
feeding America's map the meal gap 88.5%
of New Hampshire's children are food
insecure meaning that these children
don't have reliable access to
appropriate quantities and quality of
food that they need to meet meet their
basic
needs this equates to more than 21,000
kids in New Hampshire these numbers are
based on data from
2021 um and we suspect that current
numbers are much higher after support
ended that was in that was in place
during covid the increasing number of
school pantries and backpack programs
being established throughout the state
exemplifies the need for increased
access to food for those 21,00 th000
plus children currently the food bank
partners with 59 School pantries and
backpack programs more than
675,000 pounds of food has been
distributed through these programs in
2023 and that's a 37% increase from
2022 adequate access to food positively
impacts a child's health there's
research that shows that it decreases
obesity
um it leads to a Better Learning
environment improves dietary intake and
ultimately reduces food
insecurity our New Hampshire children
are the future of our state investing in
the expansion of federal nutrition
programs including summer EBT and free
and reduced meals at school is not only
an invest an investment in the future of
our children but also their communities
and our state as a
whole in addition to expanding these
Federal nut nutrition programs for
children within s SP 499 I don't want to
leave out the major impact that adopting
the elderly simplified application would
have on our New Hampshire seniors with
fixed incomes this application could
reduce some of the administrative burden
on New Hampshire's Department of Health
and Human Services and simplify the
process for older adults to apply for
SNAP benefits which we know is a barrier
by funding these programs we'll be
improving the infrastructure that
provides our most vulnerable populations
with access to sufficient safe
nutritious food that they need in order
to maintain a healthy and active life
please join me in reducing food
insecurity by passing SB 499 happy to
take any questions you
have questions from committee
M seeing none thank you for your
testimony okay thank you
all right next hear from Karen Hebert
from Department of Health and Human
Services good
afternoon my name is Karen Hebert I'm
the director for the division of
economic stability at the Department of
Health and Human Services
and I'm Brian Clark general counsel for
the division of economic stability and
Mr Clark would you fill out a pink card
when you finished not right now okay I
apologize I should have added his name
to
it so I can certainly answer questions
that any of the members of the committee
have with respect to either the elderly
simplified application process or summer
EBT I will leave the rest of the
provisions of the bill to my colleagues
from the Department of
Education questions Miss Hebert
representative walner then represent
mire so I would like to know what what
the process is for New Hampshire to be
able to um do the simplified
application and do we know now how
many elderly and disabled fall in that c
how many do we have presently on um
receiving SNAP benefits and would you
see this as a way of incre that there
would be increased participation and
this is all federal the benefit is all
federal is that correct that is correct
it is a federal benefit the elderly
simplified application program is a
program that states can essentially be
requesting from the US Department of
Agriculture uh as a waiver uh to
implement this program specifically for
older adults and people with
disabilities who have no earned
income that ballpark uh estimate number
of individuals who may qualify for that
would be about 7,000
people this would allow the state to
streamline the application process and
help more people to benefit from snap uh
snap
assistance uh it would ease their access
in applying for uh those services for
older adults uh who and people with
disabilities who have may have Mobility
uh or difficulty uh accessing online
applications so essentially one of the
the the uh features of this particular
program would enable a longer duration
of time for a benefit before it needs to
be re a redetermination needs to be
made so that they don't have to every
year reapply with the same verification
forms and obtain verification
documentation to show that they're still
eligible so the benefit duration would
be longer that would also save the state
from having to process those as
well we do believe that it would uh
provide for an increase in participation
uh because it would eliminate some of
the barriers to participating in the
program the question no thank you
represent MCU thank you Mr chairman
thanks for coming um I've always thought
that food stamps are 100% Federal
program but this bill has a $12 million
general fund cost and what part of that
is
wrong so the the yes the snap program
the benefit itself is 100% federally
funded uh so but I believe that there
are other uh cost associated with this
bill that are part of the provisions for
the uh New Hampshire education
department and not ones that I can speak
to I'm happy to speak to um the cost
associated with the summer EBT program
or the simplified
application thank you
may you want to answer my question no no
okay all right um so along those lines
um we heard that this raises the um the
elig ility to
185% of poverty what is it
now so for the summer EBT program is
that what you're referring to or either
one of them yeah um how about just for
for snap in general for snap in general
for for the the PO general population
the eligibility uh goes up to 200% of
federal property level okay so however
for the summer EBT program uh the eligib
ility is for children who are also
eligible for the National School meals
program that income limit as I
understand it is 18 185% federal poverty
level the summer EBT program is
purposely a separate program from snap
there are similarities there are similar
objectives however to administer the
program it is a very separate program
from
snap just one more so so then anybody
who is eligible for summer EBT is also
eligible for SNAP is that right they
absolutely could apply for SNAP and be
eligible for SNAP as well so we see this
as a as certainly uh the possibility of
increasing the um utilization of SNAP
benefits if we were to attract others by
way of the summer EBT program thank you
have further
Ron well I know we're getting another
fiscal note yet yet another one um but
does the department know what kinds of
onetime expenditures you would need um
to do the EBT card yes would you like me
to review that yes that'd be great okay
so for one time uh standup I'll refer to
it as standup costs uh there are cost
associated with the electronic benefit
transfer vendor they are in charge of
the the card basically uh so they would
need to make a system change uh and as I
understand it that is a one-time expense
of 233,000
we would also need to change our random
moment sample uh system with respect to
the allocation of time that staff spend
on administering the summer EBT program
versus a snap program because it would
be the same eligibility staff uh so
there's a $115,000 onetime fee
for changes to that particular system
there is also a um one-time system
change well there actually two um for
the eligibility and enrollment
integrated eligibility system known as
New Heights that particular system in
order to stand up a program that would
distribute a benefit for the summer of
24 because it is the summer of 2 for
that the US Department of Agriculture
has has established this program to
begin that we would be looking at a
one-time cost of
$110,000 just to for system changes that
would support a distribution of that
benefit for the summer of
24 however there
are that being said there are a number
of flexibilities that the federal
government is is offering to States in
order to stand up a program for a summer
of 24 benefit so they're allowing states
to apply for waivers for certain
flexibilities of a number of the
requirements they have in order to uh
stand up this program but those
requirements will end up being in place
for the summer of
25 distribution benefit so the requir
ments to to meet those requirements
there are system changes that need to be
made those system
changes uh just look at
the total for
that is
$1,320
th000 so for a summer of 24
benefit the state would be seeking
$110,000 just to be able to implement
that benefit
we are asking the federal government
that we utilize an already uh
established program that is in place in
which we distributed the pandemic EBT
benefit you may remember that as long as
we're able to use that particular
process that we already had built we can
distribute a summer of 24 benefit we are
asking the food nutrition services to
approve that
plan however we will not have have the
same waivers for a summer of 25 benefit
we will be expected to meet all of the
requirements for this particular program
which come with additional system
changes also one time but at a higher a
higher price that being the
$1,320
th000 I just had a question do you see
this as a program that will continue on
so that if New Hampshire made that
investment it would be something that
would be many year it would cover us for
many years that that would be the intent
yes thank
you further questions from committee
members representative tersi thank you
Mr chairman thank you that I'll the
figures you just outlaid is that the
bulk of the changes in the new fiscal
Noe or do you anticipate anything else I
don't know if Mr Ripple can answer
that oh no feel free um the HHS
component of the new fiscal isn't going
to change it's really the doe part
that'll change as a result of the second
Senate Amendment so the table that you
see at the end of the fiscal note is
still accurate and I believe I think
some of the numbers that you just
referenced include the federal component
as well so that's the total share the
state share is reflected here in the
fiscal note thank you that's a very
important Point uh yes s so my numbers
are really the total cost of that but
the uh federal government will uh pay
for 50%
um reimbursement of those
expenses anything
further seeing none thank you
representative Heath thank you thank you
Mr chair um because of this
investment what do you anticipate will
be the return in monetary services for
people in our
state so if I understand your question
thank you we are anticipating that this
will benefit over 30,000 children in the
state so you know for a benefit of
$120 for a summer period uh for for over
30,000 children that is basically the
the intent of that benefit does that
answer your question thank
you any further questions from committee
members seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you and I guess I've got
a sign in sheet I'm going to look
at and members next
Tuesday this is this is fairly
recent I can't remember the name of the
bill but
um
406 406 recently got handed to us so
we're going to have a full committee on
10 o'clock Tuesday the
23d for the full committee then division
three division 2 will have a meeting at
11: no no no not on 406 on 296
396 whatever it is is that right
division two division two division two
is at 11
11 division three is at one along with
division
two may may I go ahead okay so so 406 is
the new thing we're going to look at 406
as I understand it to Tuesday Morning in
full Finance then after division 2 and
three has had their joint hearing on
499 division 3 will become a single
committee again dealing with 406 in our
first work session so so next Tuesday
the 23rd is a big 406 day for uh
division
three and we'll add We'll add 406
uh to division 2 at 11: as well also at
one but division two no we're we're
meeting 11 we're meeting at 11 so what
full Finance of 10 we'll meet at 11 on
406 and 499 and 499 no not not
no show up and we'll we'll point it out
joint with 499 yes we're on we do three
we're doing
396 and 406 at
11 thank you all right for this bill
sign in sheet
499 represent Heath um from straford is
in favor
representative
VOD NT
weu uh is in favor Elizabeth O'Brien is
in favor represent Timothy Horgan is in
favor Nancy vaugh is in favor and Don
McKinny New Hampshire legal assistance
in favor and just without further
discussion a correction uh division two
is not involved in 406 I'm sorry it was
assigned to division three okay but
you'll be here for the full committee
okay any further questions I thank you
all for your patience and for being
present and we'll close the hearing on
this bill how do you get to be in
Tennessee That's How do you get to be
what